playing God of War was one of the best
decisions I have ever made recently I
was able to pick up a PS5 I had a PS4
before but I never used it much since I
usually play on the Xbox since getting
this console though I've been attempting
to do my due diligence and play some of
Sony's incredible exclusives some of
which we will definitely be talking
about in the future one of these of
course was God of War and it's been an
incredible experience God of War has
been making waves in the industry since
its first entry in 2005 and with the
release of God of War Ragnarok in a
couple weeks I thought I would go
through the entire series up until this
point and not only give you a retelling
of the game's events but also critique
it along the way we'll be answering
questions like whether or not this
specific scene conveyed the emotions it
had intended whether or not the pacing
of the story was acceptable and of
course at its most basic level was it
any good as always like the video if you
enjoy and if you like this style of
content then stick around in the next
few weeks for a video on Ragnarok but
without further Ado let's get started
God of War wastes no time getting right
into the plot as we're introduced to our
protagonist known as Kratos we see
Kratos falling to his death as the
narrator explains that the nightmares
and Visions he's been having are finally
going to disappear but of course
continuing further would spoil the rest
of the story so we're actually going to
flashback and showing how things got to
this point we actually start on a ship
being wrecked by a Hydra during this
time words like Olympus and Hades are
being heard and anyone with a bit of
knowledge on the subject will know that
this takes place within Greek mythology
this is why I was so drawn to God of War
in the first place the beauty of myths
is that they're more often than not so
detailed and complex that anyone can
create a story based on the Core
Concepts and God of War is just another
drop in the bucket that is filled with
media that uses Greek mythology as the
backdrop but that's where God of War
differs as it plans to simultaneously
build and destroy its entire world over
the course of the series it also
succeeds in subverting expectations
there are many types of media that are
centered around Greek mythology and use
the gods as this Grand spectacle God of
War doesn't really do this they do hype
up a lot of the fights and make the Gods
feel powerful but most of the attention
is not on the gods themselves it's on
Kratos at various different points in
the game we'll get a few cutscenes that
slowly uncover kratos's backstory which
is that Kratos was a Warrior born in
Sparta even though he was just a boy he
had enough strength to be a part of the
Spartan Army he would then eventually
rise to the ranks and become a Captain
who managed to win every fight before
him except when it came to the
barbarians who slaughtered his Spartans
almost instantly in a last-ditch ever to
win but also save his life Kratos
pleaded to the God of War Aries to slay
his enemies in exchange for his soul
Aries agreed and killed The Barbarians
but dealing with the gods is never a
simple manner now that he was a servant
of Ares he was given more appropriate
weapons the blades of chaos they were
massive swords with equally long chains
that were permanently stuck to kratos's
flesh that he never forgot his master
but it wasn't just weapons he got he was
also engulfed by the fury of Ares which
caused Kratos to become a bloodlusting
beast who killed anyone and anyone who
dared disrespected his new master but
Ares wasn't the only one who was about
to be disrespected within this Village
was a building full of citizens two of
which in included kratos's wife and
daughter Ares had tricked Kratos into
killing the only family he had so that
nothing would hold him back which would
allow him to become the greatest mortal
Warrior of all time Kratos however
wasn't happy he had just been tricked
into killing his own family thanks to a
god he owed his life to Kratos would
never forget this memory even if he
wanted to as Not only would the memory
of this event haunt him for the rest of
his life but he was also forced to wear
the ashes of his family on his body for
his entire existence he would continue
in this nightmare that was his life for
over a decade until we get to the first
level in the game where Kratos is told
by Athena to stop Ares from besieging
Athens if Kratos were to succeed then
the memories would be gone and his sins
would be forgiven due to this order and
his past with Ares he only has one goal
kill the God of War
that is how you write a backstory
kratos's story is one of the best
backstories I've ever had the pleasure
of uncovering and his whole motivation
goes against all of Greek mythology
media the gods are not the main focus
anymore they're just used as playthings
for the real main character Kratos
everything about this series is so
dishonest to its other media that it's
refreshing to hear a different story
we've all heard about the gods being
all-powerful and getting what they
wanted but what if they didn't what if
we could challenge the gods that wronged
us and teach them a lesson that is what
Kratos embodies and this subversion is
fantastic but this feeling is only able
to be conveyed through the game's
Stellar combat doing these videos has
made me realize how much of a game's
combat can impact its story not just in
something like a final boss fight but
more about how combat can bring out its
own emotions God of War is a hack and
slash game with such a refined combat
system that you can never get tired of
it games with some sort of arbitrary
scoring system like Devil May Cry or
Bayonetta have a distinct Advantage
compared to other genres when talking
about replayability this Growing System
makes you want to improved and the only
way to do that is to play the game more
the combat of God of War feels visceral
heavy and smooth all at the same time
weapons feel like they hurt her to the
excellent sound design and the ability
to flow from one chain to the next makes
the combat feel fluid there is no better
feeling in this game than when the
combat and its combos become second
nature and you weave from offense to
defense effortlessly slowly building up
that combo meter to the triple digits
because everything finally clicked God
of War 1's refined combat makes you feel
powerful which was the sole intention
behind its design but if there was one
thing that was slightly disappointing
about its combat it's that there's so
much of it that it hinders the story's
pacing but God of War has always been
about gameplay first that's why most of
the story can be quite simple but the
game has a lot more complex themes and
emotions that not many give a credit for
one thing that does remain consistent is
The Game's ability to sync your emotions
with Kratos at any given point take this
as an example Kratos discovers that the
only way to defeat Ares is to find
Pandora's Box this means Curtis will
have to go through the temple located on
the back of Kronos for almost 5 hours
before actually getting to the objective
the length of this level also
thematically lines up with how difficult
this journey is supposed to be but
despite that it is incredibly long with
not much dialogue in between any of the
encounters but this was intentional as
right when Kratos finds the box and
takes it out of the temple Ares notices
and hurls a spear all the way from
Athens to the temple which manages to
strike Kratos and kill him to add insult
to injury Ares also takes the box from
Kratos so not only did he kill us but he
also waited for us to take it so that he
could have it for himself I just spent
the past four hours struggling through
this Temple and defeating everything in
my way just to have this [__] take it
from me right at the end Kratos was
pissed and I was pissed too that's why
when we fight Ares later the victory
feels sweeter you feel exactly how
Kratos feels and that's a hard thing to
do for the entirety of the game getting
back to where we left off God of War 1's
first level is clearly showcasing what
the game was meant to be about fast
fluid and feisty combat but then about
two minutes the game already has you
fighting at full speed right away there
are also multiple boss fights within
about 15 minutes even if it is just the
same boss at different stages the combat
is as fast as the level's progression
and all of this culminates in a
fantastic boss fight the Hydra was a
great introduction to the game's combat
because it offers both fast and slow
attacks to test the player's reactions
and just like before once that all
clicks it's a smooth and visceral fight
God of War for as much as it wants the
player to suffer especially in its later
levels it also wants to reward the
player with beautiful scenery excellent
boss design some smooth free flow
combats and breasts
if there was a trifecta of things that
made up the entirety of God of War its
violence puzzles and nudity God of War
within the bounds of the Greek Saga has
quite a bit of nudity from NPCs and
enemies being topless to just full-on
sex minigames in each entry some of it
can be wildly absurd especially the sex
minigames when context is applied to it
like in God of War 2 how a war is going
on but Kratos sees fit to blow off some
steam but just about all the nudity is
gratuitous after the fight with the
Hydra we hear that Kratos had attempted
to drink and [__] his memories away but
nothing was able to rid him of the
nightmares Kratos is a violent man but
he's also a Broken Man Too and being
forced to see these nightmares every day
for 10 years could break any man so
showing that he has an utter lack of
respect for anyone is spot on in regards
to his character when he arrives in
Athens the girls in his bed want him to
stay a little longer to which he tells
them to grab their things and leave
earlier in the game he'll meet a guy
who's about to fall down the throat of
the Hydra he then takes the guy's key
and kicks him down the Beast stomach I'm
also fairly certain he meets the same
exact guy later when Kratos gets
banished to the underworld and does the
same thing to him again what I'm saying
is that this small interaction with the
women does make sense regarding kratos's
current psyche and character at this
moment as it's showing that not only is
he trying anything to rid himself of the
memories but also that he has a lack of
respect for these women since he has no
respect for anyone could there have been
better ways to Showcase this without
needing to show topless women probably
but this doesn't really bother me too
much because it had some sort of meaning
to it what does bother me though is the
other scenes of blatant nudity this is
something that continues throughout the
entirety of the Greek Saga and
personally I just don't see a reason for
it having the women of this series be
topless or fully clothed changes nothing
it's also painfully obvious at certain
points at the whole intention of some
scenes was just to include the topless
women for show like when you rescue The
Village Oracle and the game sees fit to
flip it to its HD cutscenes right now of
all times and also make sure to capture
a few angles of her breasts and butt
it's gratuitous nudity any way you slice
it it's also just a conflict of emotions
as it's unclear whether the game wants
me to take this whole section seriously
or not on the plus side this doesn't
show up all the time so that's fine and
the game does succeed in all the other
interactions in regards to invoking
emotions especially when it comes to
lining up your emotions with Kratos
around this time Kratos will be tasked
with going to kronos's Temple which
leads him to that four hour Journey we
briefly talked about which means Kratos
gets killed and taken down to the
underworld even though this is the
remaster the original game in 2005 is
still a sight to behold and the
underworld is a great example of why
even though its entire color palette is
pretty much just two colors it's still a
beautiful piece of scenery one way the
game attempts to Showcase these sights
is with the camera godivor's camera
doesn't move when the player wants to so
by restricting this action from the
player it allows the dev team to show
what they want the player to see such as
this scene with Ares it's Grand enough
that the player will look at it but the
devs want you to look at it for as long
as they intend for you to watch it this
is the same with the underworld it's
such a gorgeous level within the game
but while it's great to look at it is
painful as [__] to play The Game's
hardest puzzles are placed here like
this multi-section puzzle where the
player has to go through five sets of
spikes and if they touch you well it's
back to the bottom for Kratos like I
said the underworld has some stupidly
hard puzzles even the temple has a lot
of tough puzzles too but I found that
both of these fit narratively within the
game World pretty well this whole Temple
is a maze because it's meant to kill
anyone who attempts to claim Pandora's
Box the reason it's so sought after is
that it holds the power to kill a god
which is why Kratos wants it it
shouldn't be easy to find a power that
can kill the gods just as it shouldn't
be easy to climb out of the afterlife so
these tough puzzles fit cohesively
within the lore I do have an odd nitpick
with the temple though because it was
stated that no being has ever claimed
Pandora's Box and everyone has died
trying to get it this is fine it makes
sense but what confuses me is that to
get here you need multiple powers from
the gods like Poseidon's trident to be
able to breathe underwater so no one
could ever make it here by normal means
and assuming there's only one Trident
which Kratos took however there people
in this trap room which is multiple
floors above the water levels and past
the Minotaur of Hades maybe there are
different ways to climb the temple but
this was never explained I don't know if
this was an oversight or something I
missed but that felt weird since nobody
should technically be up here yet once
it reached the top of the underworld we
find that the old man back in Athens has
dug deep enough to help Kratos escape
the underworld we then make it back to
Athens which has been almost completely
destroyed thanks to Ares we then find
the man himself and take Pandora's Box
back allowing us to 1v1 the God of War
Kratos is able to overpower him with
ease and Aries realizes this as well so
he sucks Kratos into a pocket Dimension
that forces him to relive the tragic
moment of his wife's passing at his own
hands Kratos defies these mind games and
prevents Ares from corrupting him aerys
then takes the blades of chaos forcing
him to fight with a sword that was
originally a piece of the environment in
an early level which I thought was
pretty cool this second fight wasn't as
interesting as the previous mostly
because I couldn't figure out how to
Dodge Aries his moves or if he could
even be buried so I had to spam my way
to Victory but overall it was a great
final fight killing Ares means that
Kratos has succeeded in his goal and can
now be at peace the memories will be
gone his sins will be forgiven and the
person who did this to him has paid with
their life or at least that's what
Kratos would like to happen Athena comes
back and says that while his sins may be
forgiven the memories will never fade as
nothing could ever erase his past this
then leads right back to the intro where
we see Kratos climbing the highest
mountain of Olympus and throw himself
into the river below but Kratos cannot
even be granted death as Athena once
again prevents him from doing so with
Aries dead there is a vacant spot for
the god of war and Kratos is going to
take that spot Kratos then does as
instructed and becomes the new god of
war and honestly he doesn't even look
that happy about it God of War 1 was
fantastic it's able to wrap up its
entire story while also setting the
stage for the next part of kratos's life
the best part about that though is what
that means now that Kratos is a god this
means we'll be luckily interacting with
more gods and demigods and if we're
lucky we might even be able to fight
them and well that's exactly what we got
God of War 2 picks up right where we
left off maybe not narratively as it's
unclear how long it's been since Kratos
became the God of War but mechanically
for sure the Combos and movements are
practically identical to the previous
game so if you happen to start God of
War 2 right after one it'll pretty much
feel the same for the opening narration
we can see that Kratos has continued to
inspire many as the God of War we caught
a glimpse of this at the end of God of
War 1 about how the war had continued to
rage on and get more destructive because
if Kratos becoming the God of War but
now we can see a bit more of this in
action during the opening moments as the
Spartans are asking Kratos for help in
their attack against the city of Rhodes
we also learned that the other gods have
shown Kratos due to his brutal fighting
obviously Kratos doesn't care about the
gods at all which is why he decides to
join the Spartans in battle but Athena
arrives and attempts to talk him down
this is also the first time we see
Athena in game which is pretty nice she
warns Kratos that the more he fights the
more wrath grows within Olympus pissing
off the gods is scary thought but for
Kratos this is just a normal activity
while it is short we do get to see a bit
more characterization from Kratos as
Athena tells him that she is the reason
he became a god in the first place
Kratos of course knows this but brushes
at offense is that he doesn't owe her
anything we've always known that Kratos
doesn't play by the standard rules he
doesn't feel like he owes people even if
they helped him and he also doesn't see
the gods as benevolent figures this is
just further confirming that Kratos
still hates the gods for what they did
to him and is still operating on pure
anger and hatred which for the player is
great Kratos hasn't changed a bit and
he's still the angry man we've come to
know and love so it's time to kick some
ass Kratos flies down the roads before
being attacked by some bird that shrinks
Kratos down to normal human size that
bird also activates this statue which is
dead set on killing him here is where
the gameplay comes in and it goes back
to what I said before about how the
combat felt immediately familiar as
Combos and button inputs are pretty much
the same I didn't play this game or any
of the games going forward back to back
because I've been working on this video
in the background for a couple months
meaning I was going upwards of two to
three weeks without playing an entry and
yet despite that the moves were
ingrained into my head the opening
minutes were a bit sloppy sure but it
didn't take very long to get the hang of
everything this consistency also
translates over the game's design God of
War 2 looks pretty much the same
graphically but there is a lot more
background detail going on from just
pure spectacle I much preferred this
level to the fight in Athens it just
feels more intense and more pleasing to
the guy and you could argue that an
upgrading console Hardware could do this
but God of War 2 was released on the
same console despite releasing a year
after the PS3 Santa Monica Studios
seemed dedicated to releasing this on
the PS2 it's unclear how the market
worked back then but it's probable that
the studio didn't want to compete with
other launch titles plus everyone
already had ps2s at the time so it's not
like the consumer base was dwindling
regardless of the reason behind this
decision it's who the team was
recognizing where to put their assets so
they could create an engaging first
impression and they succeeded of course
once again just to remind you we are
still in the first level we're not even
10 minutes into the game and we're
already fighting a boss some games like
to take things slow with their opening
levels but God of War has never done
that but while the game is very similar
to its predecessor it does change the
formula a bit God of War has started
introducing multi-stage encounters like
with this Colossus which is fought
throughout the entire level this isn't
the same for every boss but it is
showing that the dev are experimenting
with new methods of combat however this
method ends up coming with a handful of
button problems and qtes while they
aren't bad on their own these systems
tend to take some of the fun away when
it comes to fighting I can see how this
sounds strange as qtes were made to make
fights more engaging if anything as it
allows the player to do moves that are
impossible to do with just the
controller but personally though I've
always liked being present in the fight
the whole time another issue that you'll
also notice very early on is that you
need to do something else other than
fight because the bosses usually become
staggered after enough hits which means
you're supposed to do something in order
to hurt them even though the scenes are
well put together I just feel
disconnected from the actual fight as it
turns what's supposed to be a proper
fight into a glorified puzzle and God of
War has enough of those already overall
I like God of War 2's first level a lot
more than the previous game although I
think the Hydra was still a much better
fight during the large-scale invasion of
Roads Kratos will hear from Zeus who
offers to help him craters clue doesn't
want to but Zeus is kind enough to offer
up his Blade of Olympus to use this
though critical have to sacrifice some
of his Godlike powers that he can use
some of the Blade's energy this however
was completely intentional Kratos
thought that the bird in the intro was
Athena betraying him but this bird is
actually Zeus he had purposely created
this conflict between Kratos and the
Colossus that he'd be forced to use the
Blade of Olympus which would take his
Godlike Powers away Kratos is now a mere
mortal and can barely put up a fight as
is so Zeus can easily overpower him and
kill him with the Blade of Olympus Zeus
also monitors that the cycle must end
here something that is extremely
important for the series going forward
Kratos is then taken down to hell for
the second time but also for the second
time is saved as the narrator says that
kratos's death is something they could
not allow we didn't get to see the
identity of the narrator who is none
other than Gaia also known as Mother
Earth herself this reveal was quite
chilling as the Titans are very
intimidating creatures Gaia wants Kratos
to work with her which is why she offers
him a pegasus which takes him to the
island of creation this place is where
all life began and is home to the
sisters of Fate Gaia wants Critters to
go to the island and Rewind time back to
before Zeus killed him so he can stop
Zeus himself so a lot was just mentioned
so allow me to provide a bit more
context in Greek mythology the very
first people were a group of beings
called primordials Gaia was one of them
but another was called Uranus he was the
son and husband of Gaia the two ended up
having children who became known as the
Titans the Titans were extremely
powerful deities who ruled over mankind
one of whom we've already met as Kronos
as one of the Titans in fact he plays a
very pivotal role to the story as Uranus
didn't like The Offspring he created in
an attempt to get rid of them he hid
them inside Gaia it's assumed that he
actually hid them in Tartarus the
deepest part of the underworld but
considering Gaia is the personification
of the earth it's still technically
inside of her she was very displeased by
this so she had Kronos one of her
children castrate Uranus which he
succeeded in doing so this would be the
start of the cycle while it is an
unofficial cycle there is a continued
theme of Sun's killing their fathers
Chrono somehow expected this to happen
or was possibly told this by the sisters
of Faith since they can literally
control time and realize he needed to
prevent this from happening to himself
this is why a later katsimosho Kronos
meeting a woman and eating her baby this
is his wife and sister Reya who is also
a Titan he ate them once they were born
to prevent his possible death however
Reya conspired against him and gave him
a rock wrapped in a blanket she was sick
of burying children not being able to
nurture them so she hit her final child
away on an island far away from kronos's
eyes we learned that Gaia was the one
who took care of this child and while
you may not be able to tell who it is
now this child is actually Zeus Zeus
would live in secret until he believed
it was time to strike he then released
his brothers and sisters on kronos's
stomach and the siblings battled against
the Titans these aforementioned siblings
were a Demeter Hera Hades Hestia
Poseidon and Zeus we don't hear much
about them though as some are either not
mentioned in the series or only in
future titles as the cutscene is really
just trying to show us that Zeus is
continuing the prophecy Zeus then
summons the Blade of Olympus and puts an
end to the Titan rule the Titans were
not killed though but rather tortured
the only one that we hear about though
currently is Kronos who we know was
forced to wander the desert of lost
souls for eternity Zeus now the leader
of the Gods wants to stop the prophecy
from happening to him this reveals some
incredible information about the game
but only if you're paying attention and
are aware of the cycle a lot of this
information was found on my own God of
War likes to use the mythology as a
backdrop in not much else we could still
look to the mythology to understand some
of the intricacies if we want to but a
lot of it will not be mentioned
sometimes to the game's detriment since
the myths can be quite complicated at
times it would have been nice to learn
about some of these characters in game
like this Titan named Typhon nothing in
the game tells us what happened to him
or if he's important he just feels like
a wasted opportunity speaking of Titans
we get to meet another later called
Prometheus but we actually do get to
learn a bit about him Prometheus was the
Titan who sided with the gods and helped
them win the war against the Titans even
though Zeus respected him for this he
would eventually punish Prometheus as he
was caught giving the fires of Olympus
to mankind Zeus then made him mortal and
cursed him with undeath he then tied him
down and now forces him to be eaten by
this Eagle until he dies only to be
revived shortly after he begs Kratos to
kill him and he surprisingly does this
is the first time Kratos has shown some
true Humanity within him but I feel like
it's not as simple as it seems I think
the main reason is because a
prometheus's situation he was put here
by Zeus someone Kratos hates and
Prometheus was also trying to help
Mankind and Kratos was a human before
becoming a God so he he does respect
Humanity a bit this leads me to believe
that if Prometheus was just some Titan
who had a different crime and wasn't
punished by Zeus he may not have helped
him obviously killing a person isn't
exactly helping someone but Prometheus
wanted this to happen if he truly hated
him he would have left him now I could
be looking too far into things which I
have been known to do on occasion and I
try not to sometimes but that didn't
work because I ended up doing that again
anyway after talking with Prometheus
Kratos then cuts his chains but it
doesn't release him he only dangles in
front of the fire pit he wanted to be
killed in now I'm not terrible at puzzle
games but oftentimes I think of things
differently than the game intends like
this puzzle Prometheus is choking to
death and dangling from a chain the
first thing we should do is make sure he
falls into the pit the game thought
differently though as to actually get
him down we need to spend about 30
minutes going through the rest of the
level to get a bow that will shoot him
down instead this wouldn't be the last
time me and the game would be out of
sync like this but this one in
particular still puzzles me eventually
Kratos will make it to the island of
creation and something occurs throughout
this one section that I found rather
interesting when saving a game the game
says that Gaia is giving us the
opportunity to save our progress this
used to say Zeus in the first game this
relates to how Zeus and the other gods
gave us power so that Critters could
take down Aries but now Gaia is helping
Kratos since Zeus tried to kill him it's
a small detail and I really liked its
inclusion the question though is what is
guy's goal some of it is revealed
towards the end of the game so we'll
talk about this later but do keep in
mind that Gaia clearly wants something
and is using Kratos to achieve that
after his arrival Kratos needs to move
the steeds of time which according to
the mythology was a gift from Kronos to
the sisters of Fates that he could
change his fate its purpose was to pull
the island of Creations that it wasn't
at the edge of the world thanks to the
Earth growing bigger over time this part
of the game really highlights the
designer's skills in creating large
magnificent lands like this it also
hearkens back to a previous point I made
about this game's camera being fixed so
that the devs can control what the
player can see after this criticus will
come across various different characters
like Icarus Uriel the Barbarian King
Perseus and a Spartan warrior all of
whom are here to change their fate just
like in God of War 1 many of the people
in this world are trying to find the
prized item of the current game and God
of War 1 it was Pandora's box but in God
of War 2 it's the sisters of Fate the
main difference between the two games
though is that there's now a lot more
story that can be told from this
perspective as everyone wants to change
their fate for different reasons sadly
we don't learn too much about why the
Barbarian King wants to change his fate
because of what happened between him and
Kratos which is when Kratos killed him
with the blades of chaos and was then
cast down to the Underworld for it
Perseus wanted to seek the sisters that
he could get his wife back as she was
presumably killed and taken by Hades his
presence in the game is rather
interesting though because perseus's
main claim to fame was that he killed
Medusa but Kratos already did that which
of course begs the question of what his
life is like in this game compared to
the mythological counterpart but we
don't get to know as for Uriel and
Icarus we don't really know why they're
here to see the sisters either it's
possible that Icarus wanted something
regarding his wing since that is the
center of his myth and Uriel is a sister
of Medusa so it's possible she wants her
back considering we killed her last game
but this wasn't communicated to the
player at all and honestly it's quite a
shame as it could have been a nice way
to Showcase all the different reasons
for people to see them the final person
cradles will meet is a Spartan warrior
the same one from earlier in the game
and the only reason he is currently
dying at this moment is because Kratos
fought him in a dark room and couldn't
see him it definitely feels a bit forced
and was done this way so the player can
see the results of their actions but the
emotion that resulted from this was at
least still there the Spartan Warrior
came here to change the fate of Sparta
because it was attacked by Zeus kritos's
face also clearly tells us that he has
saddened by this not just because Sparta
is his hometown but he had attacked one
of his men once again more
characterization from Kratos as he's
showing a bit more humility than before
throughout this level Kratos will use
these translators to recite some of the
words required to open the building
housing these sisters of Fate Resurrect
The Phoenix and battle the Kraken all
within about one hour just like with God
of War 1 the pace of the levels
complements the gameplay Critters will
eventually meet the sisters of Fate all
of whom refuse to help Kratos as we've
seen time and time and again anyone who
doesn't help Kratos will likely die and
the same happens to the sisters I
actually really like both the fights
regarding the sisters there was the
fight with locasis which was a bit more
combat focused and the other one with
Khalil though was a bit more puzzle
focused and if felt like just the right
amount of both I also really like the
irony of trapping the Two Sisters of
fate in a mirror essentially writing the
sisters of Fate's own Fates and the fact
that one of the fights takes place on
the sword again from God of War 1 was
another nice touch lokasis also shows us
how powerful these sisters really are
she claims to be the reason the gods won
against the Titans and the reason that
Kratos was able to make it through all
of his battles it's this Cockiness
though that would seal their Fates as
Kratos defeats all of them Kratos uses
threads weaved by the sisters to travel
back in time when Zeus was about to
strike him and intervenes preventing his
own death and now allowing him to kill
Zeus as he had originally intended this
however brings into question the
possibility of a Time Paradox since he
had saved his old self from dying which
means he should have been saved in the
beginning by his old self it's never
explained how this is possible but maybe
it's because the sisters in the island
exist out of the Realms of time but that
could also just be a stretch on my part
Zeus and Kratos then fights in another
multi-stage encounter which was really
fun and a nice way to end the game
Kratos hoping to trick Zeus pretends to
surrender to which he then grabs the
Blade of Olympus and plunges it into his
stomach a Athena arrives to stop him and
even sacrifices herself to save Zeus
Kratos is confused as to why she would
do this but Athena explains that Zeus is
Olympus and if Zeus were to fall so
would all of Olympus this idea of God's
controlling things and then those things
disappearing if they die gets put out
more in God of War 3 so it was a nice
touch to see this slight tease of the
events to come Athena also reveals the
biggest information drop of the game and
that's that Kratos is Zeus's son this is
a massive piece of lore because it not
only means that Kratos is part God but
it also forces us to recontextualize the
game's events as Zeus talks about ending
the cycle referring to Kratos killing
Zeus Kratos after this interaction comes
back to the island and then rewinds time
again back to the war between the gods
and Titans with the intention of
gathering the Titans when they were at
full strength and using them to defeat
Zeus and the gods Gaia also seems to
know that this would happen as she says
that she was expecting Kratos this is
possibly because she is omniscient in
some sense considering she was there
when the world first began it seems like
according to the cutscene all the Titans
are back although I'm unsure if Atlas is
a part of the group especially because
we do meet him earlier in the game and
we can see that he's still holding up
the world and if we assume that when two
of the same beings come together due to
time travel one will eventually
disappear which means that either Atlas
is still down there or he isn't and is
climbing up this mountain with the other
Titans but that should inevitably cause
some problems for the world considering
the fact that he's holding it up but
that detail was never explained but this
final cut scene is the end of God of War
2. even though it ends things on a
cliffhanger which the sun might be quite
annoying I didn't mind it since now the
next game can fully dedicate its time to
this upcoming fight instead of just
throwing it in halfway through that next
game would also be the final game in
terms of story order so this game has a
lot riding on it God of War 2 though was
a pretty fun game personally I think God
of War 1 was a lot better as God of War
2 suffers a bit by not explaining a lot
of the small details such as the time
traveling whether or not Atlas is with
the group what Uriel or Icarus were
doing at the island and just the basic
details about some characters like Atlas
Perseus and Icarus but it does manage to
set up the game really well and was a
nice way to get a lot of the players
excited for the end of The Saga but that
wouldn't happen just yet as I said this
game has a lot riding on it and for the
next three years the story would not be
shown to the general public but we did
get a small prequel in the meantime
chains of Olympus is the first of two
titles released for the PSP and is a
prequel to the whole series as the
gaming industry evolved many large
companies attempted to create the next
big thing Nintendo seemed like they were
on a hot streak with the Wii and the 3DS
so both Microsoft and Sony attempted to
try their hand at these products
Microsoft opted for a weak Loan in the
form of the connect and well we don't
really have to talk about that one but
Sony had quite a lot of success with
their PSP and later PS Vita portable
gaming was and still is a huge market
and chains of Olympus at the time was a
god of war game that you could play
anywhere you wanted further more chains
of Olympus is exactly that a recent
series we just discussed called Dead
Space had a spin-off title called Dead
Space extraction it was an unreal
shooter for the Wii which came from a
survival horror game these genres were
bought as far apart as you could get but
chains of Olympus and the future ghost
of Sparta are the exact same thing the
same old God of War just portable
nowadays most won't be taking advantage
of this since I had to play this via
emulation so portability is sort of out
the window but it is interesting to at
least think of how cool that sounded
when it first released however while the
initial concept was interesting the
actual game really isn't the gameplay is
still the same as before which
ultimately isn't a bad thing but that
stagnancy of its design does bring down
the game even further when compared with
the story after a while the combat in
this game can be a bit repetitive
especially when there is very little
narrative breaks in between but what did
make it worth it was the story God of
War 1 and 2 had some pretty good stories
chains of Olympus doesn't which makes
the combat even worse as now you're
wasting time fighting guys just to get a
meager cutscene for a game you've likely
already ridden off by this point this is
due to chains of Olympus being a prequel
one thing prequels will have a
disadvantage in is Stakes depending on
when the prequel was released it can
create different problems a game like
Gears of War judgment is a great example
at the time it was the most recent
release and the trilogy ended on a solid
note so it seems like it was a choice by
the devs to keep making gears games
despite the story finishing God of War
also does this with Ghost of Sparta and
Ascension but more on those later many
of the stakes in a game like that are
gone because of an old character shows
up then you know they live and if a new
one is introduced they either die or
disappear in some way leaving their fate
up to the imagination chains of Olympus
though is different people knew what God
of War 3 was coming the ending of the
second game even says so the stakes are
still there but this allows for some
leeway as characters can be introduced
in this game but then show up later
because the story isn't finished a
perfect example of this is actually
Helios who is sort of the main focal
point of the story and while we don't
get to see him in the game except one
cutscene at the end his fate does not
need to be determined yet since the
story isn't over this essentially makes
chains of Olympus a small Side Story
that fits within the over-encompassing
narrative and that size does become an
issue chains of Olympus is a short game
even by God of War standards as it takes
around 4 hours to complete but it also
keeps the same style as the previous
games in terms of Storytelling just in a
more condensed fashion the very
beginning of the game starts with
another large-scale battle this time
though it's the Persian army invading
the city of Attica you start to get a
feeling that things are starting to get
very repetitive even if it is just the
presentation as the Basilisk is just the
Hydra and Colossus fights from the
previous games but not nearly as
interesting it just sort of felt thrown
into the battle because as the team
needed to keep that consistency of an
intense first level what really starts
the story though is the sun literally
falling out of the sky Helios god of the
sun was captured and it caused this
Chariot to fall out of the sky this
means that Morpheus God of Dreams is
able to move in on the cities of Greece
and gain power since Helios was holding
him back his fog puts people to sleep
and it also caused the same thing to
happen to the gods with the exception of
Athena at least momentarily as she
explains to Kratos that he needs to save
Helios we battle through various enemies
until we meet EOS in The Chariot EOS is
helios's sister and says that Atlas has
taken Helios this is once again before
Kratos works with the Titans to take
down Olympus so he still sees the Titans
as horrific beings like most of the Gods
EOS also says that she will convince
Zeus to release the nightmares from his
head if he succeeds obviously this
doesn't happen but it's nice to see that
the gods still disrespected kratos's
wish even back then the game has us go
through various rooms and corridors that
we can get to The Chariot and the sky it
was at this point I started to lose
interest though one because the game was
doing it again where we spend an ungodly
amount of time in one area area just to
progress which makes you feel like you
really aren't progressing at all but
also because Morpheus and his role are
still not addressed yet we don't know
how he came to be why he can manipulate
people with his fog or why Helios was
the one thing keeping him from taking
over the world
Kratos then rides the Chariots which
take him to the underworld he then meets
the ferryman Caron who defeats him and
throws him further down into Tartarus at
this moment this is the first time this
happens so I feel like this should be a
huge moment Kratos is literally in hell
but it's sort of brushed off I know
Kratos actually died in God of War 1 as
opposed to being taken here like in this
game but I still feel like it should
have been a bit more important than what
seemed like a routine pit stop in here
is where Kratos discovers that the
change that once Tao's Atlas are broken
he then climbs out of Tartarus to get
back onto the boat defeats karon and
then eventually makes it to the Groves
of Persephone she is the actual culprit
of the events that have recently
transpired I also really like Persephone
as her motivations and actions line up
properly she was kidnapped by Hades
owner of the underworld she planned on
getting out of the underworld and
returning home but Hades had tricked her
into eating the curves pomegranate which
forces her to stay here for a specific
time she in the mythology is the reason
for the Four Seasons she goes to the
surface in Spring which is why plants
and trees start to grow but returns in
the fall when leaves in Flora start to
die out it's a really cool story and
it's actually told in game for once
which I loved Plus her reasoning for
trying to destroy the gods makes sense
as she was betrayed by them so honestly
she and Kratos are more alike than they
realize Persephone also gives Kratos a
really compelling Choice he can either
choose to fight or stay here in the
Elysium Fields with his daughter
throughout the game we've been hearing a
flute being played which is the same
song Calliope used to play We also see
her quite a few times in the Underworld
and obviously Kratos will follow her
here this is the first time he has seen
his daughter since the incident so
without hesitation Kratos removes his
power and blades and enters the fields
but Persephone tricked him basically
it's not a choice at all at least not
one that is interesting Persephone
explains her whole plan which is a bit
odd but then says that she released
Atlas so that she could destroy the
pillar that separates the Earth from the
underworld this then would cause the
world and Olympus to crumble this would
also kill her and the underworld but
she's okay with that because she's done
with the gods betraying her so Kratos
can either let Persephone continue her
plan thus meaning he won't be able to
see his daughter again or gain his power
back and stop Persephone meaning he
won't be able to see his daughter again
obviously Kratos can't stay here in the
Elysium Fields because of the next game
but that's the issue that comes at
writing a prequel this could have been a
pretty compelling choice and honestly it
seemed like Kratos would have chosen his
daughter over fighting if Persephone
hadn't planned on killing them alongside
her destruction the cherry on top of all
this is what happens right after if you
ever wondered why button-mashing prompts
and qtes went out of style it was
because of stuff like this to push
Calliope away the player needs to mash
the circle button three times it is so
jarring that I almost thought the game
was playing tricks on me even worse
Kratos also immediately gains his powers
back by just killing a few residents in
here which makes me wonder what the
point of relinquishing his power was in
the first place I know why Persephone
made him do it but if it was that easy
to get back then it defeats the purpose
of what this Choice meant Kratos
sacrificed all his strength and his
blades that he could visit his daughter
this is a huge decision and not
something that should be reverted within
a few seconds Kratos ends up confronting
Persephone who was helped by Atlas on
occasion during the boss fight we also
learned what was discussed in God of War
2 regarding atlas's current fate as we
can see how Kratos trapped him down here
Kratos goes back to fighting Persephone
and then she dies let me repeat that
again a God has died I I know Persephone
isn't exactly considered a major God but
still this is a very important event in
the game World Persephone and the
mythology is the daughter of Zeus and
Demeter meaning she is an Olympian just
like the other gods there are many
arguments regarding Persephone and the
myth as some see her as a minor goddess
and thus not important but others rank
her amongst the strongest but that's not
the point the point is a God has died
and Kratos and the other gods brushed
this off as a normal event once again
this is also an issue that comes at
writing prequels because since Aries was
considered the first Dead God in the
series Kratos should not have killed one
yet so either no Gods die and thus the
story takes a hidden quality because
nothing happens or a God dies but can't
be explained since Aries was technically
the first thus the story takes a hidden
quality to top it all off once
Persephone dies her explosion resulted
in the pillar finally collapsing leaving
Atlas to hold up the world Kratos then
takes the Chariot and returns to the sky
allowing the sun to return and Morpheus
to retreat firstly we never see Helios
once Persephone claimed to have used
Atlas to capture Helios but we never see
him during the boss fight it just seemed
like he was captured one moment then
freed the next also we never hear
anything about Morpheus in fact he
serves pretty much no purpose in this
story okay that's not entirely correct
as it's probably because of him that
Persephone was able to enact her plan
without the gods intervening but
Morpheus was just thrown into the story
and then taken out without any
explanation it's just really really hard
to care about this story when the game
doesn't seem to care either all chains
of Olympus really does is explain to the
player what was discussed in God of War
2 regarding Atlas then shows why Hades
hates Kratos in God of War 3 since
Persephone was his wife and then shows
Helios so when you do see him in God of
War 3 you can point to him and go that's
the guy from the last game the only one
that was worth the 4-Hour Journey was
the fate of Atlas but that could have
been explained in a future main series
title or even in God of War 2. change of
Olympus has the weakest writing of the
series at this moment I don't mind the
fact that it's a prequel or even that
it's short but these restrictions make
storytelling that much harder and chains
of Olympus is a great example as to why
the best part about this game though is
that it was short meaning for someone
who's playing the series back to back or
for you watching this video the game
only took up a little bit of our time
and now that its time has ended we can
get back to the real story and continue
where we left off
God of War 3 is undoubtedly the best
game in the Greek Saga the combat is
intense and the stakes have never been
higher everything has been building to
this moment the fight between Kratos and
the gods of Olympus in a tier where I
learned why God of War 2 was put on the
older Council but in God of War 3 on the
PS3 allows the most intense game in the
series to stand out amongst all its
peers things are as bloody and as gross
as before but the new PS3 Hardware
really excels at showcasing the brutal
nature of kratos's anger organs and
entrails are never staying in a person's
body when Kratos is around centaurs are
being disembodied and Titans are being
cut open from the inside there is just
so much Gore in God of War 3 and I
couldn't be happier to see that what
it's not just the gore that has changed
but the gashable designs of well
everything has changed Kratos the Titans
the gods even the sky boxes of places
like Tartarus are just gorgeous the
story is also ramping up so the hardware
has to as well plus anyone who recently
just got a PS3 May pick up this game to
start their journey and while not
exactly a great choice as they're
missing out on some key details you can
deny that the opening of God of War 3
could easily took anyone new to the
series take this as an example in each
of the releases so far the ending of the
game resulted in the death of a god Ares
Athena and Persephone were the only Gods
to have died in those games it took the
game's entire run time for God to die
compare this to God of War 3 where
within 30 minutes Poseidon is dead I'm
not even joking Kratos literally kills
Poseidon within 30 minutes of starting
the game God of War has always tried to
create an engaging and intense first
level God of War 3 clearly needs to top
its predecessors and what better way to
do that than a fight with a God the game
also carries over those multi-stage
encounters for the previous game and
they make way more sense in this entry
as the god should not go down that
easily so they make the fights last
longer and feel exhausting which is
exactly what Kratos would be feeling at
this moment the app Poseidon dies pretty
early on in the game but you're also
fighting him from the start of the game
and it takes a whole 30 minutes just to
put his ass down it's this back and
forth of constant battle where it seems
like each side is on the cusp of winning
that really adds to the intensity Kratos
does irreparable damage to this spider
horse thing that Poseidon summons and it
feels like the fight is going your way
until it literally hooks onto Gaia
through her mouth in an attempt to drag
her off the mountain Kratos of course
fends it off but then Pasada comes back
as a part of the amalgamation which has
another layer of difficulty you are
constantly fighting with this thing with
all you've got thinking when the [__] is
this thing gonna go down the arena for
this fight is incredible as well as the
whole fight is atop Gaia and because
she's not only climbing up the mountain
but also being dragged down by Poseidon
critic has to constantly move across her
in order to get stable ground but by far
the best part of all of this is
Poseidon's actual death as not only is
Kratos literally beating this man into
paste but the camera changes to a first
person view of Poseidon so we can see
exactly what Poseidon is seeing and
looking at Kratos from another
perspective is terrifying the final blow
sees Kratos gouge his eyes out before
throwing him off the mountain into the
sea and just like we discussed in God of
War 2 killing God's has consequences as
Poseidon's death causes a flood to arise
over the land but a flood is the least
of Mankind's worries it's going to get a
lot worse later just to remind you once
again this is still only 30 minutes into
the game God of War 3 easily has one of
the best opening levels on I've ever
played but this intensity wouldn't be
able to stay the whole time so the game
has to dial things back a bit because
Gaia ends up betraying Kratos claiming
that he was only seen as a pawn so the
Titans could fight the gods again to
which Kratos loses his grip and falls
back down to hell again for I think the
fourth time now this time however is a
lot like chains of Olympus where Kratos
Goes to Hell by traveling there as
opposed to dying and being dragged down
there as usual though Kratos loses his
powers upon arriving so the game can get
us back to zero again but it also seems
like his Blade's powers are weaker as
the blades look damaged somehow though
Athena arrives and provides Kratos with
better weapons Athena is quite important
to the story as she's the only one to
have died so far that can still exist in
some way Athena also wants Kratos to
defeat Zeus despite trying to save him
last game so she clearly has a motive
but at the moment we're unsure what that
is the only thing we do know is that
Athena was able to achieve some higher
level of existence after dying but once
again how that's possible is still
unclear upon arriving in the Underworld
Critters will find a note belonging to a
Perseus not much is known about him in
game but his mythology can give us a few
Clues as to why he's here according into
the mythology he was a friend of Theseus
who we briefly saw in God of War 2. the
two then made a pledge to carry off the
daughters of Zeus bessius chose Helen of
Sparta but Perseus wanted a more
dangerous prize which is why he went
after Persephone wife of Hades from
chains of Olympus we know that
Persephone is dead but this was luckily
before God of War even happened so she
would still be alive at this point we
can find a note that corroborates this
tale as it talks about perthius trying
to take Persephone away from Hades
considering the state we find him in
it's likely that he failed and was
captured by Hades and is now being
tortured for eternity what's odd though
is that he drops Apollo's bow when he's
killed which Kratos uses for the rest of
the game God of War has done this before
and it's always given me a massive
headache Kratos just seems to come
across Godly weapons by sheer luck like
how Poseidon's trident was just sitting
inside the temple atop of Kronos and how
Apollo's bow was just given to some
random person I probably shouldn't be
looking that hard into this but it's
just odd how there was never an
explanation as to why these Godly items
are either left or unguarded or given to
random people it doesn't take away much
from the story but just as the series
pulls me in with its action in constant
combat it always seems to pull me back
out when random things like this just
appear without any mention down here in
the Underworld is also the chain of
balance and the judges of the underworld
both of these are pretty
self-explanatory the judges judge those
of the underworld to see if they're
worthy to pass into the paradise of
Elysium and the chains of balance
connect the underworld to Mount Olympus
this is not to be confused with the
pillar of the world from the previous
game which connects the underworld to
the regular land of Earth the reason
this chain of balance is important is
because it meets in the middle connected
by this device called The Labyrinth
inside the Labyrinth is Pandora the key
to Pandora's box but I'm getting a bit
ahead of myself Greta still has a long
way to go before he gets there on the
way to Hades he'll find various notes of
people here and while most aren't too
important I do like that God of War once
again references the captain from the
first game as a sort of running joke he
also appeared in God of War 2 when
fighting the Barbarian King and it's
just funny to see him every time
eventually Kratos will meet Hephaestus
Kratos will ask him where the flame of
Olympus is as he needs it to defeat Zeus
hephestus doesn't help him but there's a
reason for this after numerous cutscenes
and discussions will come to learn the
following Hephaestus was the creator of
Pandora's Box this box was made to house
all the evil in the world that was
created during the first Titan War there
is nothing physical in the Box because
it houses for a lack of a better word
invisible entities evil thoughts and
sins are inside the Box things like fear
greed and hate these things were created
when the Titans lost Zeus put these
Powers inside the box that they wouldn't
escape and infect the world we will then
learn later that Athena feared this
Box's power so she also created a good
power called hope and put that inside
the Box these Powers would bless or
curse the people it touched when Kratos
opened the box in God of War 1 he
released the evils onto the world and
many of them cursed the gods of Olympus
fear is what consumes Zeus as he became
paranoid that his son would usurp him
which is why he attempted to kill Kratos
in God of War 2. this likely would not
have happened had Kratos not opened the
box and the powers of fear had not
corrupted Zeus's mind we'll also
discover later that the powers Kratos
used to defeat Ares was the one Athena
created the Power of hope these Powers
both good and evil were dangerous as
they could change the balance of the
world instantly which is why Zeus put
them in the box Hephaestus is then
created the box and gave it a magical
key which was Pandora a human looking
girl who was also technically the
daughter of hephestus she was created to
be the key that would unlock access to
the Box the plan was originally to put
the Box inside the Flames of Olympus
this was not only on the mountain of
Olympus which houses all the gods but
the flame itself could kill any God or
Mortal it touched Hephaestus created
Pandora as the key to dispel the Flames
since no one would ever think a young
girl was the actual key however over
time hefestus grew attached to her and
saw her as his daughter so he tricks
Zeus and convinced him that the safest
place to hide the box was atop kronos's
back which is why we go there in God of
War 1. he did this so that Pandora
wouldn't need to be sacrificed as her
death would remove the Flames after
discovering Kratos was able to open the
box he came back to Hephaestus realized
he lied beat him to a pulp and put the
box where it should have been inside the
flame and took his daughter Pandora
that's when Zeus would commission a man
named Daedalus to construct the
Labyrinth so Pandora could be hidden
away from the world Daedalus is
important as he is a master architect
with the reason he's doing this is
because Zeus promised him that he'd be
able to see his son Icarus again who you
may remember died thanks to Kratos
ripping his wings off learning all of
this was refreshing it's been a long
time since the series has actually
explained itself it can still be
considered a massive lore dump seeing as
all this was shown to rakatsim but it's
better than nothing Pandora's Box has
also been seen as an anomaly within the
God of War World so having this context
is extremely important and also makes a
lot of sense as to why the box was there
in the first place this also creates a
bit of suspense as Kratos is going to
eventually need Pandora to open the box
and hephestus isn't going to let him
sacrifice his daughter so the two are
eventually going to butt heads over this
speaking of Pandora Kratos will come
across to her later as a golden statue
except he is unaware of who she is at
this moment she's able to telepathically
talk through them and when talking with
hefestus we can see that he created tons
of these luckily so that he could be
with or maybe even talk with his
daughter but none of them seemed to work
after the brief talk cradlesomega to the
Palace of Hades and one thing that's
rather interesting is that inside this
Palace is a coffin with Persephone
inside I was a bit caught up in the
intensity of the first level and you
likely could have been too and may have
missed this detail but Ares is also seen
in case in an ice during that level this
is Odd as the gods explode when they die
but it doesn't seem like their bodies
explode alongside it they just release
an explosion which was likely the power
that they wielded inside them these two
are also located in this place as a way
to preserve their bodies so they don't
Decay Persephone is also one of three
reasons behind hades's rage as he's
upset that we killed his brother
Poseidon his wife Persephone and his
niece Athena which is why he tries to
kill us this rage was probably already
within Hades but the powers of Rage from
Pandora's Box luckily heightened this
emotion in him we can even assume that
Rage or hatred also consumed Poseidon as
he was pretty adamant about trying to
kill Kratos as he's the first Target he
sets his sights on most of this though
is also backed up by what occurs in the
next title Ghost of Sparta the fight
with Hades is gross as we not only get
to see his real face for once but his
skin also gets torn off by Kratos so his
organs are showing throughout the fight
similar to how Hades took down Atlas
Kratos rips Hades his soul out of him
this kills him but similar to Poseidon
this will have damaging consequences as
The Souls of the underworld are now left
to roam free afterwards Kratos will meet
with Gaia again and as Kratos has never
taken betrayal lying down he cuts off
guy's hand which casts her down to
presumably the base of the mountain
again right after this is where Kratos
interrupts a match between a God and a
Titan and after interfering we can
discover that huh wait a minute that's
the guy from the last game Helios is
injured thanks to Kratos and he also
meets a gruesome fate which I'd argue is
the worst so far it's not only does
Kratos literally rip his head clean off
but he keeps it for the rest of the game
and uses it as a lantern since Helios is
the god of the sun it makes sense why
the sun immediately goes out after this
happens however this situation was the
exact same plot from the last game which
would mean that Morpheus should be
making his move on the land but once
again that never gets mentioned it's
clear that Morpheus was only able to
gain ground thanks to Helios being
captured and his power was strong enough
to put the gods to sleep the team likely
wrote themselves into a corner here
because there'd be no reason as to why
Morpheus couldn't do it again but that
would also make the final confrontation
pretty boring as all the gods would be
asleep and not able to fight back so
they probably thought it'd be better if
Morpheus wasn't mentioned at all this is
once again why prequels like this can be
a problem for the story it causes mask
confusion because players know these
characters exist but the one time it
would make sense for these characters to
show up they don't part of this is the
blame on chains of Olympus for crafting
its story around those characters but
it's also one God of War 3 for not even
bothering to mention him it's possible
that Morpheus could have died after
chains of Olympus or decided to not
partake in this chaos but it's never
explained and it honestly feels like it
should be Morpheus and his powers are
dangerous in being able to see some of
those powers in action would have been
nice even if it was just a slight nod to
him I know that was a long rant on a
character that never actually got screen
time in their own game but when you
introduce characters like this It's
Perfectly Natural to call into question
what they would be doing during a time
like this and to not mention Morpheus at
all is a missed opportunity Kratos will
then Journey upwards using the chain of
balance as his guide to reach the Flames
of Olympus here's where kritos will
discover that Pandora's Box is here this
then leads to what we talked about
before regarding Kratos needing Pandora
to remove the Flames that Critters can
open the box this section of the game
may also cause a large amount of
confusion because Kratos and Athena are
both right and wrong in this discussion
as we know Kratos opened the box and
used the power of Hope to defeat Aries
Athena assumed he used the powers of
evil against Ares when he actually used
the power of hope that's why Athena
assumes the power of Hope is still in
the box when it's actually not this can
cause some confusion as the player at
this point doesn't even know what power
Kratos was using or the fact that he
even had a name to begin with I figured
I would clear this up because just like
Pandora being needed to open the box I
saw a lot of discussion regarding this
game's story and its massive
inconsistencies but for the most part
it's been pretty consistent with its
events Critters at the end of this
discussion realizes that he will need
Pandora and says to Athena that a simple
child will not bother him this is quite
ironic even what happens later but there
are more pressing matters afoot as
Hermes is currently taunting Kratos and
using his speed to outrun him his
Cockiness will lead to his eventual
tragedy you may even call it Greek
tragedy as Hermes the god known to be
incredibly fast has his legs cut off
forcing him to crawl away from Kratos
his death also releases a plague onto
the world infecting many of the servants
on Olympus and most likely mankind as
well we are roughly about three to four
hours in and Kratos has already killed
all four gods that we saw in the
introduction Kratos is on a killstream
can also let's add one more Hercules
Hercules is fighting Kratos because of
jealousy or Envy as while he was forced
to carry out the 12 labors which are our
core part of his history Kratos got to
kill Ares and be the God of War
spectating this fight is Hera wife of
Zeus who seems to be drinking her
problems away but that doesn't really
seem to be working she'll meet a similar
fate soon enough but Kratos has to deal
with some other women mainly Aphrodite
and Poseidon's princess Poseidon's
princess has been the target of many
controversies regarding this game and
it's pretty clear to see why Kratos can
keep this door open without holding the
gears in place so he determines that the
next best thing to do is to take the
enslaved lover of Poseidon and use her
as a means to stop the gears he ties her
to the wheel and while it goes down as
intended it stops halfway as her malt
corpse is keeping it from moving I am
genuinely surprised this made it into
the Final Cut of the game yes it does
show that Kratos literally cares about
no one in this game but that's also not
true Pandora ends up becoming a huge
problem for Kratos later as he refuses
to use her as a sacrifice Kratos is
literally willing to fight Zeus without
the powers in the box if it means that
Pandora can live this is likely because
she is just a child in his eyes and
doesn't deserve that fate okay well what
about her she was forced to be
Poseidon's wife and is still chained up
in her own Chambers what beef does
Kratos have with her
he doesn't and that's the problem it's
completely unnecessary in the attempt by
the devs to sexualize the scene a bit by
making her topless is the icing on the
cake to this atrocious decision
Aphrodite on the other hand is all about
sexuality in fact you can have sex with
her as many times you like as long as
you're willing to put up with the same
exact moaning and dialogue every single
time she doesn't serve much purpose to
the story at all actually she's just
here for those players who've been
itching to find the sex mini game in the
latest entry since it's been seen in
every game thus far her portal does take
us right back to Hephaestus though who
we discover is her husband it's also a
little awkward when Hephaestus asks if
she conquered another God of War
implying that she has cheated on him
multiple times and the fact that Kratos
just continues talking to the man whose
wife he just had sex with definitely
makes for an uncomfortable conversation
at least for the player that is Kratos
doesn't seem to care that budding of
heads I talked about earlier is about to
come up as Hephaestus is clearly against
Pandora being killed so Hephaestus plays
along and asks Curtis to get him a
specific Stone this stone is in the pits
of Tartarus and will allow Kratos to
enact his revenge on Zeus however he's
completely full [__] as he was
planning on tricking Kratos by Shocking
him to death when he wielded the blades
it's actually kind of sad as he uses his
dying breath to beg Kratos to spare
Pandora this like detour seems to be a
waste of time but we actually got to
activate the bridge that was stopping us
originally and also got to see probably
the best fight in the game so far down
here in the pits of Tartarus is Kronos
who is banished here once Kratos opened
Pandora's Box this fight reaches Peak
levels of Gore as we rip his fingernail
off cut blemishes off his skin bust open
his shoulder cut open a giant hole in
his side and even have to slide down his
throat when Kratos gets swallowed it is
gross but incredible all at the same
time you'll likely notice by now that a
lot of kratos's actions have
consequences even ones that don't result
in him killing someone opening the box
banished Chronos to Tartarus made
Hephaestus get beat up and forced to
stay in the Underworld and this act also
likely caused Aphrodite to cheat on him
Pandora is trapped in The Labyrinth
because of us and furthermore the
creator of the labyrinth Daedalus is
also in his current predicament due to
Kratos Daedalus is the creator of the
labyrinth and we know that he's only
doing this because Zeus promised him
he'd be able to see Icarus again but not
only is the fate of Icarus tied to
Kratos but the opening of The Box caused
Zeus to hide Pandora which is why he
asked Daedalus to make it Kratos has not
only shaped the world through immediate
action like the death of the Gods but
through other actions as well Kratos in
the next game Ghost of Sparta gets
called Death incarnate everything he has
done whether intentional or not has some
sort of consequence and oddly enough
some of these actions actually come with
positive consequences defeating Aries
stopped him from warring with the other
gods defeating the sisters of Fate
stopped them from manipulating time and
killing the gods will stop them from
ruling over Humanity the problem though
is that the solution to these problems
and the effects of them are usually way
past their logical conclusion the gods
are harsh and Despicable beings so let's
kill them and doom the whole world in
the process Kratos on an alignment chart
would likely be a chaotic good but none
of these really make Kratos a good
person because he's not doing it for
anyone but himself he wasn't killing the
gods that they stopped being malicious
beings he was killing them because he
wanted his own personal Revenge he also
didn't kill Ares because he was waging
more he did it to get revenge and maybe
get his memories taken away everything
he does is selfish but it's interesting
to see all these positive and negative
effects Kratos has on the world even
from doing something as small as opening
a box Kratos on his way to find Daedalus
will meet Hera again and of course B
kills her her death ruins a vegetation
around the world so this likely killed
off all the crops in the land Kratos
will then find the Labyrinth and also
find Daedalus he is tied up as According
to some of his notes Zeus needed another
prison so which is why he commissioned
Daedalus again not knowing it was for
him the whole time this may also have
given us more information on a timeline
for the game as this Labyrinth didn't
start construction until after the box
was opened and we know that there was an
unknown amount of time between God of
War 1 and the beginning of God of War 2.
these notes point to it being roughly 12
years that Kratos served as the God of
War before being killed by Zeus
ultimately that detail isn't too
important but it's interesting
nonetheless after his conversation with
Daedalus Kratos will finally meet
Pandora the only person in the game
who's able to quell kratos's rage just
like when we were discussing the
princess of Poseidon krito sees her as a
child and maybe to an extent even sees a
bit of calliope in her too that's why
Kratos is so protective of her which is
odd as he did just kill her father less
than an hour ago but Kratos does say
that Hephaestus was right to protect her
so even though he did have to kill him
because of his betrayal he respected
Hephaestus a bit because just like him
he would do anything to protect his
family in order to get Pandora to the
flame of Olympus he needs to break the
chain of balance that the Labyrinth will
rise to the top of Mount Olympus this
means that will need to travel back down
to the underworld and it's becoming
pretty clear now that we're revisiting
old areas and honestly I like this a lot
the other games to an extent felt
realistic but the world of God of War
feels much more connected here than in
its previous titles Kratos wound up
getting Pandora to the top but Zeus
interrupts the two and grabs Pandora
despite being the literal King of the
Gods Zeus has the worst accuracy I've
ever seen as he manages to throw Pandora
onto the one ledge that is still
standing instead of just dropping her
down the pit this is followed up by
probably the funniest scene in the
series and that's a 2d camera
perspective reminiscent of all the
Glorious fighting games that have made
waves in the industry as dumb as this
looks it's actually amazing if there was
any style that God of War could steal
and make it look great it'd be this one
given all the blood and action that is
at the core of this game I genuinely
would not have minded if they kept this
for the whole fight they already have
the juggling mechanics in the game and
one of the weapons has a soul summon
ability that is similar to the assist
moves all they're missing is just two
giant health bars at the top sadly I'm
not allowed to get what I want as after
enough damage the game cuts to Pandora
using the opportunity to sacrifice
herself Curtis attempts to stop her but
after Pandora tells him that he knows
what the correct choice is he lets her
go and sacrifices her life but it was
all in vain Kratos opens the box and
it's empty I cleared this up earlier so
that this scene made a bit more sense
remember at this point in time Kratos
does not know that it's empty the reason
it's empty is because all the evil of
the world corrupted the gods and the
power of Hope is still in Kratos he just
doesn't know it Athena assumed he used
the evil powers to defeat Ares but it
was actually the power of Hope the
reason Kratos isn't allowed to use this
power is because of his past and his
hatred towards himself for killing his
family this guilt was preventing him
from being able to use that power of
hope soon he'll be able to confront
those fears as after a quick fight with
Zeus and Gaia who shows up right at the
end Kratos kills Gaia and Zeus with one
thrust of the Blade of Olympus but Zeus
has some sort of Astral form similar to
Athena that allows him to still fight
Kratos Zeus then uses the power of fear
to try and kill Kratos which is why he
goes into his own psyche and attempts to
find those powers of Hope despite this
being more literal it could also be seen
as metaphorical Zeus has been constantly
taunting Kratos about the death of his
family and how weak he is so he's using
fear to deter Kratos from continuing his
Rampage while Kratos is trying to hold
on to his hope the hope that he'll
succeed in his revenge and the hope that
one day he can end his suffering Kratos
goes into his own mind and forgives
himself for what he did allowing him to
move on and not be brought down by his
own guilt and fear Kratos then snaps
back to reality and is now able to kill
Zeus which we do in first person as wild
as that may seem it's not as crazy as
what happens after as the game instructs
us to tap the circle button to beat Zeus
this keeps going until the whole screen
is covered in blood but you can keep
doing this for as long as you want I
kept going for at least another five
minutes just to see if something would
happen this is truly a fantastic design
Choice as it allows the player to really
enact their revenge on Zeus and allow
them to keep punching until they feel
satisfied Kratos then gets a beautiful
look at all his destruction before
Athena confronts him about the power she
made the this leads into the argument
between the two which reveals all the
stuff we talked about earlier regarding
Kratos having the power of Hope but not
knowing it and after Athena realizes she
demands kritosuke for the power back
Kratos refuses as he still has one more
person left to kill himself this is the
only route that this journey was going
to go as Kratos has no home to return to
and his quest for vengeance is complete
he did what he wanted but the only way
to truly end his own suffering is to
kill himself since Kratos has died he'll
be able to release the power of Hope
back into the world and Athena is pissed
her goal the whole time was to get that
power back but now she's unable to do so
once again Kratos is ruining people's
lives just by doing anything the final
scene is Kratos bleeding atop Mount
Olympus but an after credit cutscene
shows that he crawled away while this
does end up connecting to God of War
2018 that was a long ways away at this
point so this was likely made just in
case the team wanted to make more
sequels since the perception of God of
War was not dying down and if anything
this entry raised it even higher God of
War 3 is probably my second favorite
game in the series and easily the best
one in the Greek Saga God of War 3 was
the god of war game that many have been
waiting for the game where Kratos Dukes
it out against all the gods and Santa
Monica delivered the story was also
fantastic as the lore surrounding the
world was expanded upon and the fact
that this is the game that finally
concludes kratos's story also helped as
well this end credit scene should
technically take us to God of War 2018
but a lot of time passed before that
came to fruition and in between that
eight year wait two other games will be
released in the meantime
Ghost of Sparta would be the second and
final game release for the PSP the
structure and feel of this game are
identical to that of chains of Olympus
since it's on the PSP though that means
it's going to be a short game with an
equally short story ghost of Sparta is
centered around kratos's brother Deimos
who was taken by Ares and Athena when
they were kids there was a prophecy that
a marked Warrior was going to change the
fate of Olympus and since damos had a
notable scar on his face the two Gods
assumed that he was the marked Warrior
they were clearly wrong despite thinking
that they may have pulled this out of
their ass for the purposes of the story
there was a hint to this in God of War
1's treasure menu but that wouldn't see
the light of day until this entry but
what makes this more satisfying is that
technically in story order this is the
next game after God of War 1. this takes
place in between that 12-year period
where Kratos was the God of War before
relinquishing those powers during the
Battle of Rhodes meaning if you played
in narrative order the cheese of demos
is shown in the following title but once
again we're back in the same hot seat
that chains of Olympus previously sat in
where the story is not going backwards
but the only difference that the game's
story is now finished we know kratos's
story now the stakes have been lowered
drastically as now we enter that
territory we discussed earlier when
talking about chains of Olympus since
the story is finished there's no way to
write in new characters into future
titles so older characters who show up
aren't going to die and new characters
who appear for the first time in the
series will likely perish before the
credits roll this game is caught between
a rock and a hard place because they
either have to kill off the new cast
they just introduced or somehow explain
why this character shows up in this
entry but nowhere else Ghost of Sparta
opted for the easy solution which was to
just kill him off instead Kratos gets a
vision of his mother and somehow knows
that she's in Atlantis so he sets out on
a journey to the underwater city the one
advantage goes to Sparta has going in is
that the team behind the game knew how
far the PSP could be pushed they also
knew what worked and what didn't work in
their prior release so this allowed them
to push the hardware to its absolute
limit it may not be obvious when looking
at the foreground but the background art
has surely gotten an upgrade as the
volcano and whirlpools are stunning to
look at even if you can only catch a
glimpse or two at a time during the
combat it felt nice to take a quick
breather in between games to go back to
a more classic style for a time and I'd
even argue that I missed it what I
didn't miss however was the older games
pacing when it comes to story ghost of
Sparta carries on the leg Legacy of its
ancestors by doing what those games did
with its narrative long combat
Encounters in between story cut scenes
and any cutscenes we do receive are
pretty much the same exact cutscene with
a slight bit added at the end like we're
slowly assembling the pieces of a story
together but this isn't some murder
mystery where Kratos has to remember all
the pieces we can catch the bad guy this
is the most important cutscene in the
game as it explains to the player who
Deimos was to Kratos and what happened
to him here damos's name roughly 30
minutes in and then it's around two
hours later to where we see a cutscene
of the two brothers together it's not
until another hour later that the second
part of the cutscene plays where we see
two Gods carrying his brother away this
is like a four to five hour game and we
finally get to see the fate of demos and
why we're even going on this journey in
the first place this whole time I was
just following along with Kratos because
he clearly knew something I didn't and
it's hard to feel invested when you
don't get the basic fundamentals as to
why the character is doing what they're
doing the first person Kratos will meet
is his mother Callisto who was in a tomb
behind a door of Poseidon she states
that she was brought here by kratos's
father Kratos will then ask who his
father is to which she seems to whisper
something before turning into this
demonic creature this comes out of
nowhere and is presented well but a lot
of questions still need to be asked the
main question as to why she turns into a
demon is never explained many speculated
it was because she was cursed that she
could never utter Zeus's name to him but
as we see she turned into a monster so
either this curse changes her before she
reveals her Identity or it only happens
after regardless it's clear that the
curse activated and if we assume it only
activates upon saying Zeus's name why is
Kratos not more surprised by this
Revelation and furthermore if he knew
his father's identity here why is he
shocked when Athena tells him in God of
War 2. if we are to assume that she
never got the chance to tell Kratos then
that would make the reveal of God of War
2 more natural but the question of why
she even turned into this beast in the
first place is still on the table
looking at this encounter from any angle
no matter how hard you try won't produce
any worthwhile results we do however get
to see a bit of regret in Kratos as he
starts questioning himself and asking
what he's become too bad after this
entry Kratos goes back to killing
thousands of people with his Spartans so
the idea that Kratos might be coming to
terms the fact that he's a monster never
actually gets brought up again which is
another shame one problem short stories
will run into is a lack of
characterization and screen time when it
comes to specific characters there isn't
a whole lot of time to make a meaningful
cast of characters so you have to really
make sure the audience understands who
they are and also give the viewer a
reason to care about them the one
character goes to Sparta does that with
his demos as he has a connection to the
main character kratos's mother also
succeeds in that department as well even
though she only shows up for 10 minutes
but once again it's due to her
relationship she has with Kratos making
a character be related to the
protagonist raises their importance as
we're going to be going on this journey
with the main character anyway so we
might as well get to know the family
while we're here Ghost of Sparta is
successful in making the player care
about kratos's family but not anyone
else the next two characters will meet
are Thera and lenaeus Linnaeus works
here in the volcano to make sure
everything is in working order as this
volcano is located near Atlantis so any
eruption could be devastating to the
nearby land the possible creator of that
destruction is Thera a Titan who sets
the base of the volcano Kratos meets
Thera who then mentions what we know
from God of War 2 how the Titans will
reunite together with Kratos as Gaia
foretold but now is not the time Kratos
then takes there as power which allows
him to imbue his blades with flames
Thera is then able to escape and cause
the mountain to erupt we never see her
again after this any knowledge of her
disappears the moment we leave this room
lenaeus is similar in this respect as we
meet him once and then it's not until
another hour or two later that we
finally meet him again but it's only so
Kratos can throw a spear at him which
makes him fall into the electrified
water these two characters are
incredibly forgettable and their
inclusion really serves no purpose to
the overall story these characters also
both seem to be completely original
people that don't exist in Greek
mythology and this is a Telltale sign of
the state of the series new original
characters get barely any mention as
they don't have any mythological
background to use as a backstory and is
to the point where we're running out of
people to meet and kill so the team is
forced to make their own characters to
help with the narrative continuing to
work on something you're passionate
about is commendable but there does come
a time when it needs to be put to rest
God of War is now starting to enter the
state in which the game is running out
of ideas but is trying so desperately to
keep people interested because the team
wants to keep making more God of War
games one way to keep someone interested
is to create an engaging environment and
while the volcano level is deaf
definitely a piece for the eyes its
reason for being here is confusing
Kratos is here to
actually I'm not even sure why Kratos is
here he gets dragged to this location by
this beast called asila and then causes
the volcano to erupt which just so
happens to shoot him towards the city of
Crete a city connected to Atlantis it's
just sort of by pure game logic that he
arrives here which doesn't exactly help
the volcano also makes a mess of
Atlantis which is likely why Poseidon
was so hell-bent on fighting Kratos
right away in God of War 3. when Kratos
makes it through most of the city he'll
come across some Spartan Warriors and
one of them while holding the torn apart
Corps of his friends states that they
have angered the gods and this
destruction is a message from the gods
more specifically the personification of
death Thanatos Thanatos is a very
interesting antagonist at least from a
mythological standpoint as he's a
primordial so he's stronger and older
than any of the Gods on Olympus in fact
a lore tablet and Ghost of Sparta says
that death's domain the realm of
Thanatos is feared by Mortals and gods
alike thenitos clearly knows that Kratos
is coming for his brother which is why
he sends his daughter Aarons to deal
with them similar to the previous two
characters we talked about not much of
her is known or learned as she dies
within 20 minutes of meeting her the
fight against answer though is at least
pretty entertaining afterwards is more
entertainment in a more narrative way as
Kratos returns to his home in Sparta
everyone is respectful and praising him
except for this one dissenter who
believes Aries is the real God of War
and not Kratos he gets stabbed in the
stomach for saying that I do wish
however that more was done with Sparta
as its only purpose in the story is that
the Temple of Aries here and Sparta has
something Kratos needs meaning he would
not have come had this item not been
here being in Sparta should be a big
deal for him as not only do all these
people look up to him it's his hometown
now I'm not expecting Kratos to drop
whatever he's doing and go the
traditional hero Trope where the
hometown Adventure returns and starts
helping the community again but I do
wish more time would be spent here in
typical God of War fashion though the
only thing we can actually do here is
have sex with the entire brothel it's
leaning more towards the absurdity side
since all these women keep jumping on
the pile like it's a relay race but all
of it is starting to become very
tasteless now once kritos makes it
closer to the temple the following scene
shows Kratos fighting his younger self
which is defending the skull needed to
enter the domain of death why this is
here is unknown but given that Deimos
was taken by air reason is now under the
guise of Thanatos it's clear that the
two had some sort of friendly
relationship I also once again have to
ask how the hell does kratos's mother
know this even exists we never hear
anything about kratos's mom until this
game so we can't really come to a
plausible conclusion as to how she knows
this information given that her husband
is Zeus it's possible that he told her
this but I'm surprised the two are even
on speaking terms assuming that curse
theory is real without any concrete
information to point to it just feels
like a way for the game to move the plot
forward without going into consideration
as to how the characters would actually
know that information after this another
character is tossed into the mix but his
identity is a bit more recognizable King
Midas is down here in his Cavern and is
distraught that he had accidentally
turned his daughter into gold Midas is
seeing things which is why he puts his
hand in the lava Because he believes
it's the River Styx Kratos then gets the
amazing idea to throw this man's entire
body into the lava so that he can cross
Kratos then sets off towards Atlantis
and it's really here where we can see
how detailed the backdrops are within
Ghost of Sparta the fight on the boat is
also pretty intense as the lightning is
constantly raining down on the boat so
you're having to die charge both the
enemies and the lightning go through
Atlantis will take us back to where we
were earlier in the game but we are not
able to enter it thanks to the skull we
recently acquired death's domain is a
nice looking location but I never felt
the fear that a location like this
should come with it looks just like any
other ruined building with a few unique
details in the background this also has
nothing to do with the graphics either
as the underworld in God of War 1 is
still one of the most visually stunning
places in the series but death's domain
doesn't really imply a sense of death or
Decay Kratos ends up finding Deimos and
while Kratos is happy to see him damos
isn't demos blames him for not
protecting him back in Sparta which is a
little odd considering they were kids
plus Callisto also lied to Kratos about
demo so it's not like he could have
known anyway after their scuffle then
his house will interrupt the two and
attempt to make Kratos suffer by killing
damos Thanatos travels out of death's
domain to the suicide Bluffs the same
place Kratos jump from in God of War 1
and flights Deimos after Kratos rescues
him the two make up and end up fighting
Thanatos together the fight with
Thanatos is actually really enjoyable as
it's the first time the series has
delved into Cooperative combat also the
few times they work together are well
choreographed and conveyed to the player
that the two really work well together
damos ends up taking a fatal blow during
the fight but so does Thanatos and
Kratos is able to kill the god of death
demos dying was pretty much guaranteed
considering his lack of appearance and
future titles so this didn't really come
as a surprise one thing that did
surprise me though is that goes to
Sparta had considered the ramifications
of Thanatos dying it's not a great
explanation and it's vacant best but
that old man from God of War 1 arrives
again and says that Kratos has become
death the destroyer of worlds it's
possible he's inherited the role of
death although that's just speculation
it would connect to why Credo seems to
cause destruction all the time no matter
what he does but he's also been doing
that since God of War 1 so that wouldn't
exactly make much sense this however
does prevent things from spiraling out
of control as in God of War 3 the rulers
of things died in Ghost of Sparta Kratos
just swaps places with Thanatos so this
would explain why the world hasn't gone
crazy not that the literal
personification of death is now dead the
final scene is Kratos burying his
brother before the old man buries
Callisto and says that only one remains
likely in reference to to Kratos similar
to chains of Olympus Ghost of Sparta was
short so there wasn't a whole lot of
time to really engage with the plot but
taken as a small Side Story the game did
pretty well and was a lot better than
chains of Olympus I'm glad we also got
to see a bit more about kratos's family
as that was something that hasn't been
explored in the series so far the major
downside to this game though was its
insistence on just throwing in
characters only for them to die or leave
within 10 minutes Thera Linnaeus Midas
and Aarons just get thrown into the game
and then take it out a few minutes later
and it's really hard to care about these
characters at all when we barely even
get to speak with them it's pretty clear
though from just this game alone that it
was running out of ideas and was
struggling to come up with new ones that
then leads to the most difficult
decision a team of devs will have to
make do they continue making games or do
they stop putting something down rather
than keeping it alive is a tough
decision but in the case of game design
it's often the right one yeah the game
could generate more Revenue but it can
also cost you your integrity so the
decision to end the series you've just
spent the past half decade trying to
create is a tough one and Santa Monica
Studios could not let their pride enjoy
cross over into those Pearly Gates so
they opted to keep their life running
for just a little longer
God of War ascension is the final game
in the Greek Saga and it's clear to see
why it's not a great game one of the
game's problems though is not even the
game's fault the God of War Series has
two places where Side Stories can take
place before God of War 1 and in between
God of War 1 and 2 since both of them
have large time gaps in between each
other it's impossible to do a story
between two and three since one starts
with the other leaves off and after
three is impossible since the story is
over that's why chains of Olympus and
Ghost of Sparta opted for the
aforementioned times to make their
stories that doesn't leave the team with
a whole lot of options especially if
it's before God of War 1 as the team has
to make sure no Gods die in the story or
to ruin the death of Ares so The Logical
answer would be to do the other option
and make a story closer to Ghost of
Sparta but we know from that game the
team is running out of gods and
mythological creatures to kill so now
they have to scrounge up more characters
that we have never seen in the series
only for them to die by the time the
game ends so what does ascension end up
doing well let me give you the summary
of the plot Kratos is being tortured by
three women called the furies because he
vowed to break his oath with Ares doing
the this will allow him to take Ares
down and rid himself of the nightmares
had this been brought to the writing
room around the time chains of Olympus
was being made I can almost guarantee
you it would have been thrown out this
story complicates kratos's backstory and
Kratos is not a complicated character it
just feels unnecessary but since the
team is literally out of options there
is only one left it's pretty clear from
just that summary alone that the game is
stagnating the gameplay hasn't changed
since 2005 with honestly the biggest
change coming from this game which is
that the blades of chaos now have
multiple Elemental attacks besides that
pretty much all of it is the same to be
fair the games did add new weapons but
once you examine them closely you
realize how much of this game still
hasn't changed the blade of Artemis from
God of War 1 functions almost
identically to the Blade of Olympus from
God of War 2 and Zeus's Gauntlet from
chains of Olympus is very similar to
Hercules Gauntlet from God of War 3 so
the gameplay is on a downward spiral and
now the story is coming with it God of
War as a Trilogy is impressively
tight-knit to its own detriment as it
makes the other games pale in comparison
to it since everything needs to be built
around them but those games are only
made to be built around each other
that's why the PSP games feel so
disconnected from the main three titles
and Ascension is being added to this
list as this game is a complete prequel
of everything in narrative order this is
the first game in the series and what a
wild start to the series this will be
the beginning of the game shows a brief
cutscene that details our main
antagonists when time first began there
was a war between beings called the
primordials they're very War shaped the
world itself this War caused Madness and
rage amongst the beings and from these
feelings manifested Three Sisters called
the furies the unique detail about them
is that there's something we haven't
seen before they're not Gods Titans
primordials or Shades they're just
Furies and they're the only ones of
their kind the furies also don't care
much about the world so they were never
a threat to people they only cared about
honor and servitude they would watch
over the blood Oaths made by the gods of
Olympus and would punish those who
didn't follow them their first victim
was the hekatonkares named aegeon he
swore an oath to Zeus but after some
time stopped listening to him and thus
went against their oath the fury sought
him out and made him become an immovable
prison which was then used to house the
other people who also broke Oaths we
start Ascension with Kratos being held
prisoner by one of the furies at this
prison Kratos is being tortured by the
fury megiro before she takes it too far
and gives him the opportunity to break
free honestly I really like the furies
they're probably the best part of this
game which is why it's such a relief
that they're the antagonists even though
they are basically the modern day
versions of the sisters of Fate I ended
up liking them a lot more they have
actual personalities and we are given
enough time to actually see them
throughout the game megira is more about
physical torture due to her ability to
do things without ever questioning them
she operates purely in the moment she is
hot-headed and will take things too far
because she's just focused on the task
ahead her sisters however are a bit more
level-headed whereas megira focuses on
physical punishment tissiphone focuses
on mental punishment by Conjuring up
fake realities for the prisoners and
getting them to believe that what
they're seeing is real both of these
sisters also end up getting more and
more desperate throughout the story
magira in the beginning uses her insects
to attack Kratos but then after
realizing none of that works we'll
summon the heck of tankeries to attack
Kratos this then reaches a point where
she needs to get the job done herself
which is how she ends up losing her arm
there's a phone in the beginning has
some pretty convincing Illusions but
after a while she starts getting
desperate as she creates an illusion
right in front of Kratos he was able to
see right through this illusion
instantly which of course annoyed her
the only one who's a bit more common
Collective for the most part is electo
she is the final sister and is sort of a
mix of both but she's also the leader
between the sisters so while she doesn't
dish out as much punishment in this game
as her sisters do she does play an
important role like I said I really
enjoyed the furies and watching them try
their own methods on Kratos was really
interesting especially when their
current methods weren't working so they
had to Pivot to new ideas but none of
those are working either the opening
level also does a really good job of
showing us how the sisters operate while
giving us a wonderful display of the
scenery and how the level itself becomes
a part of the combat this fight is
reminiscent of the encounter with
Poseidon atop Gaia as both of them have
multiple moving Parts which means that
the small Arenas we go through will
constantly be shifting back and forth so
you're never in one location for very
long each area is also traveled to using
various methods like grappling and
climbing all of which are stunning to
look at the actual enemy design is
incredible as well my main gripe though
is that the camera loves to pan back
about 30 feet farther than it should
which creates a problem like this where
it's so far back I have no idea where I
am Ascension also really wanted to up
the ante on its production by making the
camera shake a ton which also ends up
creating more problems one other nitpick
I had was the graphics themselves the
game looks great there's no doubt about
that but this change of color palette
caused even more problems as it's hard
to distinguish criticals from any of the
other enemies on screen this when put
together makes some of the fights
unbearable but I will admit it was at
least playable however for some reason
after this level I had consistent frame
drops and it was hard to maintain a
steady frame rate I have no idea why
this was the case as this had not
happened in any of the other games so
far I usually don't mention technical
issues like this in my videos but I
wanted to mention this in case some of
the footage does look a bit off the
finale of this level has Kratos killing
megira and taking enamela off her body
and by now you should be wondering how
Kratos got here and how it's been 40
minutes and one of the three antagonists
is dead that's because the game is
getting a bit ahead of itself as it cuts
away flashback from three weeks ago one
of the weakest parts about ascension's
story is this back and forth between its
Advan events as you lose any amount of
tension and Pace by doing so God of War
1 did this as well but it was handled
much differently back then this scene of
Kratos jumping to his death was the
final scene in the game it was also less
than a minute long this introduction
also gives you more reasons to keep
playing as you wanted to know how Kratos
got to this point the flashbacks and
Ascension are all over the place as the
story starts in the middle then goes to
the beginning then close to the finale
then back to the beginning then to the
finale again it's just all over the
place and while it's not hard to piece
the story together it just feels
unnecessary the only reason they did it
this way was likely because the team
still wanted an engaging and intense
first level as the actual beginning of
the game is very slow paced the reason
Kratos was taken to this prison was
because he wanted to break his oath with
Ares later we figure out that after
Kratos pleaded to Aries and was given
the blades of chaos he was also tasked
with completing three blood tasks the
tasks were the killing of his enemies
the killing of the innocent and the
killing of his family Aries had not told
Kratos about this because he would have
obviously refused this is all because
Aries had a plan to overthrow Olympus
with kratos's help Aries in alecto had a
child called orcos he was supposed to be
ares's marked Warrior but orcos failed
and was not capable of becoming a
warrior that's when he decided that
Kratos would be his new marked Warrior
which is why he assisted him all those
years ago Kratos after realizing he had
just been tricked into killing his
family renounced his oath with Ares this
doesn't mean the oath was gone though
it's like signing a contract and then
saying no afterwards that's why the
furies had gone after him as they wanted
him to become a servant to Ares so he
could overthrow Olympus and ares could
then become the new Zeus Kratos sometime
after renouncing his oath started seeing
illusions of his wife and his home until
orcos comes by and decides to help him
orko saw that Aries had tricked Kratos
into a Blood Oath and determined it was
wrong of him to do that so he betrayed
the furies and now sides with Kratos
orgos also gives him a purpose as he
tells him that there's a way to break
the oath with Aries so that he no longer
has to suffer see Kratos is not only
seeing Illusions thanks to the furies
but he's also missing past memories more
specifically the memory of him killing
his wife and daughter we know from God
of War 1 that Ares wanted Kratos to be a
hardened warrior with no pass so that
nothing was holding him back which is
why he tricked him in the first place
this that Kratos and Aries have removed
this memory from him so he's not only on
a quest to break the oath but also gain
his Memories Back whatever they may be
if this sounds confusing it is and I'll
get to this plot hole later but just
roll with it to help overcome the
illusion orcos gives Kratos a necklace
and ring belonging to his wife so he
remembers that what he's seeing isn't
real he then tells him to find the
Oracle at the tower of Delphi as she'll
explain what to do next just like the
first level God of War ascension is
really trying to up the ante by
utilizing the new hardware to its
fullest potential like in the current
level where to open the door to the
tower Kratos needs to pull three
mechanical snakes into place so they can
rotate the tower at a distance they look
amazing but the game isn't done yet as
it allows us to have our cake and eat it
too as there's a good 10 minute section
that is just hopping from one part of
the snake to the next while fending off
waves of enemies if there is one thing
God of War ascension really excels at
it's the environmental design some of
these dungeons we have to Traverse to
are some of the best in the series and
I'm impressed they pulled this spectacle
off multiple times once we reach the
tower we can meet with the prophet who
asks Kratos for a sacrifice and typical
Kratos fashion he just continues walking
which angers the Prophet The Prophet who
goes by the name Castor also has a
brother named Pollux attached to his hip
the two of them seem to have usurped the
Oracle from her position and uses the
tower's influence to reap the benefits
the duo was also willing to kill the
Oracle once they realized Kratos is too
strong for them so they likely didn't
care for her at all and just wanted to
be seen as Gods by those who travel here
they also stole her amulet which seems
to bend time allowing objects to Decay
and heal whenever Kratos uses it the
reason the Oracle is so important is
because she has the ability to see into
the future she would use her eyes of
Truth to see future events but this
power first would end up doing more harm
than good I briefly mentioned earlier
how orcos discovered the plan to
overthrow Olympus he learned this news
from the Oracle when he confronted her
about the future when he learned the
truth he set out to Olympus to warn Zeus
but Ares got to him first Ares and the
Furies pluck the oracle's eyes from her
which is why she has none when we meet
her they removed her eyes and hid them
as far away as they could as they
thought that if nobody could find them
no one would discover their plan to
overthrow Olympus the Oracle tells
Curtis to find these eyes of hers which
are located in the lantern of delos
eventually Curtis will find a ship going
to Dallas but before he makes it time
goes back to the present for a bit and I
I do mean a bit like 10 whole minutes I
just can't wrap my brain around how this
could have been seen as a good decision
we start in the present and just killed
magira Kratos just broke out of jail and
tensions are high but now we have to go
back to the past for a while we then
finally learned some new details and
right as soon as we're about to make it
to the new area the game goes back to
the present this is also a complete
waste of time as well all we experience
in this 10 minutes is another illusion
from tisaphone and a conversation with
the Scribe of the hakatoncaris who then
tells us the same exact info we just
learned three minutes ago when on the
boat with orcos the Scribe says that the
furies were harsh to orcos and treated
him poorly or ghost pretty much says the
same exact thing in his own wording just
minutes prior so I'm confused as to why
this is even here the whole present day
section just bothers me in general
because we start with an illusion and
sure I don't know what Kratos is
thinking at this moment but considering
he was just on the heck of tonkares how
is that he magically enters a throne
room and is now talking to the King of
Sparta like the illusion is so poorly
constructed I'm surprised Kratos didn't
see through it immediately also the
following interaction with tysophone is
so bad it's hilarious she runs away but
will eventually return but now with her
pet Damon Kratos gets attacked by it and
after one single qte he steals the stone
of orcos from it and then she leaves
[Music]
[__]
it matters not that you have my son's
toy it is your heart that will betray
you
shouldn't even attempt to fight him she
just attacked him and went [__] well I'm
out of options I'll come back later the
only reason this exists is so that when
the player goes to the past and actually
uses the stone of orcos they know how to
use it when they go back to the present
this is the same situation for the
amulet as Kratos steals the amulet back
from magira but then the game decides
that the player needs to go back in time
to experience the story and then once
they find the amulet in the flashback
they're taken back to the presents that
they know how to use it in the following
puzzles it's just odd and really
unnecessary after the brief intermission
we can finally see the lantern of delos
it's this massive statue and just like
the snake it's gorgeous even in its
ruined stage it's really a sight to
behold but as we continue throughout the
dungeon we can slowly rebuild it back to
its original form this is technically
the one game in the series where Kratos
is building things rather than
destroying them it really shows that
Kratos was a different person back then
if we want to go even further this is
also the first time Kratos is making
friends orcos really becomes kratos's
one and only friend in these games he
always talks in this calm tone when
speaking with him and just really shows
that Kratos does value his assistant
it's a new side to Critters we haven't
seen before and I really like their
occasional interactions Kratos then
makes it through a good chunk of the
level before encountering the furies
again testifone along with magira are
back and this time they've brought an
illusion with them Kratos immediately
notices and attempts to remove it so it
seems like Kratos does have the
capability to sense the Illusions he
just needs to see them appear right in
front of him technically in
chronological order this is the first
time Kratos is meeting the furies which
explains why magira still has her arm
but since we had that spoiled for us we
know what's coming next Kratos cuts off
magira's arm and then a lengthy boss
fight against the Two Sisters ensues it
ends with Kratos throwing megira off the
structure and impaling to safone on a
spike but once again since we know she
shows up in the present this won't
actually kill her the game plays this
reveal off as some crazy twist as if we
didn't just see her in the present and
know she isn't dead that's the one
problem with this game's structure all
the furies live in the present so any
boss fights will have a little amount to
nothing so there's no hyper entry
generated from these fights they are
great to look at and engage with but you
already know what the outcome is before
it even happens so this is all pointless
Kratos manages to get captured by
Electro before orcos comes by and
rescues him he then gives Kratos the
stone we saw from the present which
allows him to do what orcos does and
leave a fake body behind Kratos will
finally make it to the room which houses
the eyes of truth but he wasn't fast
enough the sisters have caught up to him
and they have captured orcos they then
take the stone away from Kratos and
capture him this then leads back to the
intro where he's chained up and tortured
this is also the final time we'll go
back to the past so really quickly let
me put this game's events in order so
you can understand what's going on this
game actually starts with orcos talking
with Kratos back at the Village he then
meets with the Oracle who instructs him
to find the eyes of Truth Kratos then
finds the eyes but is then captured by
the furies after days of torture Kratos
manages to find an opportunity to escape
this causes vast amounts of chaos as
magira infects the heck of tonqueries
with her insects Kratos then battles
through all the foes in his way before
meeting with magira the two battle and
Kratos comes out the Victor with megira
dead only Tisa phone and alecto remain
which leads us to where we left off
Kratos just fended off the Daemon and is
now heading for Electro's Chambers once
again another illusion happens with this
time of his wife and daughter Kratos
almost slips manages to see through it
at the last minute now the final battle
commences between the two sisters and
Kratos and I gotta admit it's a really
good finale Electro turns into this
tentacle monster and ends up sending
Kratos into another illusion this is the
kind of thing I was hoping for using the
illusion to create completely new
sceneries honestly this might be one of
my favorite levels in the entire series
I also really like how the fight
Incorporated all the different items we
found up until this point as the stone
of orcos helps Kurtis remove himself
from the black goo the blue crystals on
the tentacles are taken away by using
the eyes of Truth and while the amulet
doesn't get much use in this fight you
could still use it as a weapon and
suspend some of the enemies in the air
everything felt useful in this fight
which I really appreciated after
defeating the duo in the illusion krato
snaps dysafone's neck before stabbing a
lecto in the chest killing the furies
for good Kratos also got to remove the
oath between him and Aries since they're
the ones that held the old so if they're
dead all the Oaths are severed at least
that's what Kratos would like to think
before the sisters died they made orcos
the oath keeper which means Kratos will
also have to put down orcos Kratos once
again showing a more softer side than in
the previous entries is saddened by this
Discovery and refuses to do so claiming
that no more innocent blood needs to be
spilled this is the same guy who will
murder countless innocence because they
got in his way it was really refreshing
to see a different Kratos even if it was
only for a short time but with orcos
dead all the furies are finished the
others are all gone but because the oath
was holding back kratos's memory as we
discussed the memory of him and his
family rushes back into his mind which
leads right into God of War 1 where we
see him constantly reminded of this
misdeed every single day and with that
God of War ascension has finished it's
clear that I haven't been that positive
when discussing this game and there's
two reasons for that firstly we need to
ask what did this story add to the
series new entries can provide us with
new information such as the existence of
the furies but I want to focus on the
big story beats what did we learn from
Ascension Ascension basically tells us
that Kratos was tricked into killing his
family by Aries and because of that
Kratos is now going to seek revenge
against him all of this was already
handled in God of War 1 in a much better
fashion and that's my first issue the
story was really unnecessary it tried to
add a bit more complexity but It
ultimately doesn't matter better prior
to this release many would assume that
Kratos after being tricked wanted to get
revenge it took a while in the first
games he was still a servant to the gods
but after some time he got his wish God
of War 1 tells us how Kratos was tricked
and why he hates Ares God of War
ascension does this too but by adding
him one slight bump in the road by
addressing the fact that he needs to
sever his bond with Ares first before he
could actually kill him we end up
arriving at the same conclusion anyway
so this was all unnecessary and to make
matters worse this whole story is an
inconsistent mess to explain let me lay
out some of the events of this game
again according to the final line of the
game Kratos had no memory of killing his
family because the oath between him and
Ares was the thing holding that memory
back it's only after severing the oath
that Kratos was able to remember these
memories what we don't know though is if
that was the only memory Ares wanted
Kratos to be a hardened warrior with no
pass so that nothing would hold him back
if the final line in the game is to be
believed the oath only removed the
murder memory this would connect to
various cutscenes in the game where
Kratos recognizes his wife and daughter
so Ares only removed the memory of
Kratos killing them but he still knows
they exist he just doesn't know they're
dead so how does this help Aries Kratos
would have returned from war and noticed
his family is missing and then he would
have gone against the god of War's
wishes because Kratos wants to find out
where his family went not knowing he
killed them because the oath removed
that memory from him so this would have
likely backfired on Ares anyway if we're
to play Devil's Advocate and assume that
it was all memories of his wife and
daughter to the point where Kratos
doesn't even know they exist then that
wouldn't make sense either as he clearly
recognizes her necklace and ring in the
intro and also talks to the illusion of
her like it is her so neither of these
actually make sense this then leads me
to the blood tasks to complete the oath
Kratos had to kill his enemies the
innocent and his family Ares tricked him
into doing this which is why he
renounced his oath to him and this is
what kickstarts the game's story but
here's the problem the oath was started
either right then and there or soon
after this event happened and since the
oath was complete Kratos had forgotten
the memory of him killing his family but
him being tricked into killing his
family is the reason he wants to break
the oath with Ares in the first place so
technically Kratos is trying to break an
oath with the God of War when without
knowing why because he doesn't remember
the reason for why he wanted to break
the oath since the oath removed this
memory from him honestly had they just
removed the memories plot this could
have been a serviceable story they could
have swapped this story with the same
thing from God of War 1 where Kratos was
told that by doing something he'll get
his nightmares removed so in Ascension
he would meet orcos and could explain
that Breaking the Bond with Aries could
remove the nightmares he then discovers
that this doesn't work until Athena
tells him that killing Ares will remove
it instead but as we know that didn't
happen either it would continue to paint
the gods as malevolent beings who use
Mortals as pawns they could have also
done away with this completely and just
had a story that was before he killed
his wife and daughter there was a gap in
time between Kratos pleading to Ares and
then killing his wife so the game could
have taken place there the final
cutscene could be right when Kratos
enters the village and then it ends so
that God of War 1 could explain what
happened at the Village this would allow
players who play in narrative order or
release order to feel satisfied in some
way but as it stands this memory plot is
just unnecessarily complicated God of
War ascension is the final game in the
Greek Saga and by now it's clear to see
that these story is running out of ideas
and the combat isn't changing all that
much either this would require the team
to overhaul the game completely but
before we leave let's look back on the
Greek Saga as a whole God of War 1 truly
was and still is one of the strongest
games in the series both narratively and
mechanically God of War isn't really
known for its story many players prefer
to play the game and use the story as a
means to drag them towards more enemies
and this is a completely valid way of
thinking and God of War really excels at
giving those players those wow moments
when it comes to gameplay but even still
its story was rather impressive it's not
going to win any awards for the most
thought-provoking or most intricate
story of all time but that story that
God of War does try to tell was handled
with care Credo serves as a vessel for
the player to enact destruction he's
become death incarnate throughout the
series he was a person who stood up for
what he believed in and would fight the
very gods in order to make sure he got
his way many movies in media portray the
gods as powerful beings incapable of
being killed God of War challenges this
idea and says not only can they be
killed but they can all be killed by one
man that's embarrassing and it's that
exact emotion that makes God of War so
intriguing how can one man create all
this destruction and still come out on
top Kratos has literally done the
impossible and in a way aren't video
games meant to do that give us control
of the characters that do the impossible
so that we feel like we're doing the
impossible yeah Kratos killed the gods
of Olympus but it was because we were
controlling him so in a way it was
really us that did all that destruction
the Greek Saga was all about action
fast-paced combat death destruction and
aggression Kratos was on a journey for
vengeance and he stopped at nothing to
finish it identifying the core ideas
behind God of War are key because it's
incredible how much of this will
disappear after this entry Ascension for
many was the last straw for the series
and having noticed this the team at
Santa Monica needed to go farther than
they ever have before with God of War it
wasn't just going to need a revamp of
the story or the combat everything
needed to change and after a few years
of development that change would come
God of War 2018 is the boldest decision
I have ever seen a company make
everything about God of War is no longer
present in this entry of whom gameplay
it's a narrative it is so different that
all it takes is removing Kratos and you
could sell this as a different game but
that's what God of War has always been
about God of War is about the story of
Kratos not a story in which Kratos plays
a pardon but still the changes within
this entry are staggering gameplay has
been completely overhauled going for
more up close and personal style of
combat using a third person
over-the-shoulder camera rather than the
panned out version of the older games
the jump has been completely removed and
the blades of chaos are gone and are
replaced with the Leviathan ax all of
this though may seem like a mistake but
I promise you it's not Santa Monica
Studios knows more than anyone how
synonymous the combat of the previous
games is to the God of War series which
is why it had to go Kratos is a changed
man it's really hammer in that change
everything needed to go not just in
regards to gameplay but also narrative
structure and tone take this as an
example every single game in this video
has had an intense first level coupled
with some high octane combat but in God
of War 20 18 that's changed here is the
first moment we as the player can freely
move Kratos
I think the clip speaks for itself it's
not only boring but it's quiet
furthermore Kratos himself has changed
in the Greek Saga if someone so much has
looked at him wrong they would die but
this Kratos shies away from a child that
he can hide the scars he got from the
Blade's chains at this point we have to
ask if this is even a god of war game
anymore and to me it not only still is
but it's a much better one at that God
of War 2018 which I'm just gonna call
God of War because that title is very
annoying to repeat is my favorite game
in the series by a long shot it's the
first game in the series that felt like
story was the most important part of the
game and I'm all for it the story though
is incredible informative entertaining
and just a blast to experience most of
this though can be attributed to the
previous entries later in God of War
critics we'll be talking with this kid
who we discover is his son atreus and
the two have a conversation about
killing Kratos not only says that there
are consequences to killing a God but he
says that he was teaching him to kill
Force survival not Indulgence that is
insane to me because for six whole games
Kratos has done nothing but kill for
Indulgence this is what I'm when I said
that playing the games heightened a lot
of the experience knowing Kratos killed
the pantheon of gods versus actually
playing his Kratos when he killed that
Pantheon is such a different experience
that can only be understood once you
play them I may have hated some of the
entries in this series but seeing all of
them come together and lead to this game
made all of it worth it but this of
course segues us to the most important
question about God of War how is this
even possible and to that I say
I don't know God of War really starts
off on the wrong foot it takes place in
the Norse Realms yet despite the change
it's never explained how Kratos got here
or how he survived I have my theories of
course but nothing to back it up I
looked into this question just to make
sure I didn't miss some important
dialogue during a boat ride or something
yet the only answer I could find was
from a comic book which at the time I
didn't even know existed one problem
that comes with writing is deciding what
to say and what to save in most stories
there's usually the active plot and the
overarching plot I just need to
reference this game quite a bit but a
good example is Mass Effect 1. the
active plot of that game is stopping
sarin once you hit the last third of the
game though the overarching plot of the
Reapers is introduced so that once Saran
is stopped the team can now move on to
the real story a lot of games do this
actually where you play the game with a
goal in mind but the real plot gets
revealed towards the end and it only
widens the game world making things feel
more real and authentic but also gives
the team something to write about in the
next entry the reason I bring this up is
because there's a certain amount of
restraint that needs to be recognized or
else the story falls apart I'm sure the
writers of Mass Effect really wanted to
get into the meat of this story as fast
as possible as that's where things get
interesting but they need to refrain
from showing their hand too early it's a
careful balance of answering previous
questions but also providing more
questions that the player has more
reasons to keep playing God of War
really doesn't do this three big
questions are left unanswered how do
Kratos live how do Kratos get to the
Norse Realms and what was going on with
Athena the Athena one I'm willing to
forgive for now because that could lead
into a new plot that could continue the
series the other two though should be
answered not only are they leftover
questions that shouldn't require a whole
game to answer but it's a building block
of this game imagine if Kratos killed
Ares without the player knowing why
knowing that Kratos was tricked by Ares
is a pillar of the story and for this
new entry knowing these two questions
are as well according to the comic
apparently Kratos can kill himself which
is why he isn't allowed to die and for
the second answer it's possible that
fenrir was the reason he was dragged to
the Norse Realms the first answer is a
little bit confusing but only because I
don't remember this being mentioned in
the games but I could just be
misremembering that detail the second
one though if true is very disappointing
one because fenrir has never seen in
this game and it's also because it's
answer certain a comic book I have a
weird opinion about this and you're
welcome to disagree it would have always
felt that major questions need to be
answered in the games especially if the
series started out as a game our
previous video talked about a game
called Dead Space that series also has
books and films that add more story to
the universe the thing is though is that
was a game first so most of the
community came from the games the books
and films are for those who want to
delve deeper but not everyone wants to
do that which is why there are more
people who played the games only than
those who played the games and read the
other material God of War was a game
first before anything alternate media
like movies novels and Comics are great
but should not be the source of major
answers especially one as important as
this showing how Kratos got here would
be a good idea as long as the game
explains how so going back to the fenrir
comment if the game said Kratos was
dragged to the Norse Realms by fenrir
because he found himself in the river or
something that's great the comet can
then show the interaction so it provides
more understanding the game would give
us the reason and the comic could
elaborate on it this of course doesn't
happen God of War throughout its entire
run time will add more questions like
the origin of the world serpent atreus's
other name and the fate of Realms and
Ragnarok approaches these are the kind
of questions that start in this game but
will be elaborated on in the sequel God
of War 2018 is just planting the seed
the problem with the other questions
though is that the seed has already
sprouted it's grown withered and died by
now and yet no answer is given it is an
absolute shame because both eras of the
game's connect and needs to be answered
it just feels like the team was like
yeah Kratos is in the Norse Realms now
oh how did he get there don't don't
worry about that just look at him being
a father because that's cool right and
you know what it worked not only because
the plot about atreus and Kratos is so
well done but also because it was
captivating enough for me to completely
forget about those questions until the
credits appeared let God of War 1 this
new entry is an origin story God of War
1 didn't elaborate on the gods until
further injuries because that first
title was all about Kratos and his
backstory this God of War is the same
just created a bit differently this game
doesn't focus on the broader world of
the Norse it's all about atreus and
kratos's relationship Norse gods do
appear at some points and the game does
playing seats that will sprout in the
next title but this plot is mainly about
atreus and Kratos this is a massive of
gamble on top of the already large
gamble that is this whole game because
if the player doesn't like atreus the
whole story Falls flat but God of War
continues the theme of sinking the
player and kratos's emotions together
but better than ever before surprise
betrayal anger and relief all occur
throughout this series and Kratos and I
were in sync every single step of the
way I am genuinely shocked how while
Santa Monica pulled this off take the
first encounter with the stranger as an
example atres and Kratos while in their
home get a knock on the door this
scrawny looking man appears and starts
chatting [__] the two bicker for a bit
before the stranger punches Kratos the
player immediately thinks there's no way
this [__] just did that he has no idea
who he's up against Kratos is likely
thinking the same thing as well because
he doesn't defend himself until after
the first couple hits now you're
thinking haha you got him Kratos show
him the power of the God of War
foreign
now things have changed as you realize
that this man is a lot stronger than he
looks which is exactly when Kratos gets
more serious this kind of thing happens
all the time when the mood changes from
one emotion to the next and yet despite
the constant switching and the
difference in mindset between Kratos and
I we were perfectly in sync the whole
game a lot of this though can be
attributed to the camera you'll notice
throughout this video that the camera is
always on Kratos in one way or another
it may pan to another character for a
time but it's one continuous shot as if
someone was following Kratos the whole
game it's interesting to think about how
cool of a concept that is but seeing it
in play is still rather impressive it
also allows the store to be more
personal and also allows the player to
connect to Kratos more the previous
games didn't do this as cutscenes often
showed other characters at the beginning
of God of War 3 there was a cutscene of
all the gods lined up eager to fight if
that game had adopted this game's camera
the first scene wouldn't have been an
hour fighting Poseidon now it would have
been holy [__] Poseidon's here it adds a
layer of mystery to the game because we
don't know what's going on around us we
don't know where this stranger came from
and when he'll be back it also adds more
tension than I otherwise would have had
once the game reaches its climax because
there are multiple moving Parts
happening at one time and now the player
doesn't know what's going on either
circling back to the stranger though we
should probably talk about what's going
on here we'll eventually learn that this
person is balder brother of Thor and Son
of Odin he's here to find a giant he
mistakes Kratos for a giant because of
what happened earlier the very start of
the game sees Kratos cutting down a tree
with a handprint on it these are
protective Wards placed by kratos's new
wife Faye in the time between games
Kratos and his wife Faye also had a son
named atreus sadly Faye passed away but
at least Kratos didn't kill her this
time atreus and Kratos don't exactly get
along which is a key part of this story
one thing the previous games mentioned
but never explored for obvious reasons
was kratos's ability to be a father
Kratos just wanted his family back but
it never really occurs to you until now
if kritos would have actually been a
good father while his wife was raised in
Calliope he was out fighting in Wars he
was distant from his family but he still
loved them and in this game critic is
doing the same thing while Faye was
teaching atreus about the world Kratos
is all hunting for the family he was so
distant from them that when atreus
reveals details about himself that the
player doesn't know yet Kratos is also
shocked by the information for example
atreus has a Keen Eye for language he
can decipher a lot of old languages and
will help Kratos at certain points by
translating runes he has no idea atres
can do this the game also showcases this
with the sort of Showdown tell kind of
method Kratos is desperately trying to
hide his pass from atreus which is why
he shies away from him when his bandages
start coming off atreus after being with
Faye for a bit glances towards the door
and we can see the darkness his father
still possesses he's terrified of him
and I would be too not just because he's
Kratos but because he treats him like a
Spartan he gets angry at atres when he
does kid stuff like goofing off or
asking questions there's a few times on
Kratos tries to connect with his son by
holding him but he backs out Kratos
doesn't know how to talk to his son
which rubs off on atreus because from
his perspective even though Kratos is
trying to show affection he doesn't see
it so atreya sees him as a cold and
distant father who wishes he was better
this is also shown through gameplay as
while atres can help you he's mostly
just fodder because he hasn't gotten any
of his good abilities yet but it is
still very clear that Kratos does care
for him he tries to protect Citrus and
balder by hiding him under the
floorboards he will almost always take
the brunt of a fall so that Reyes
doesn't get hurt he'll catch him when
they go down Ledges and every single
time Spartan rage is used as a mechanic
during a cutscene it's only when atreus
is injured or taken he never uses it
once for the sake of it it's always to
protect atreus Kratos clearly cares for
the boy he just doesn't know how to show
it but like with everything all it takes
is time Kratos and atris are going on a
journey together because Faye's final
wish was to be cremated and taken to the
highest point in all the Realms Kratos
and atreus would be together on this
journey for probably longer than their
entire lives together because Faye is a
very smart woman and probably figured
that doing this would repair their
distant relationship as they're now
forced to work with one another it's
only after the fight with balder though
where the journey truly Begins for boss
fight it is actually quite fun I have a
habit of making things more thoughtful
or impactful in games especially in boss
fights even if it means I'm at a
disadvantage which is why I decided to
fight him using only my fists he started
the fight with fist so it's only fair
that I ended it with them the fight
probably would have been more
interesting since the fists don't really
have many combos especially 30 minutes
into the game game but I enjoyed the
intensity that it brought with it the
only problem is that this fight doesn't
go anywhere because balder seems to be
Invincible claiming that he can't feel
any of critters's attacks crittle snaps
his neck but as we'll soon see this
doesn't put him down after the fight
would bother the tube will set off the
highest peak in all the Realms is
actually in yotenheim home in the Giants
Kratos however believes it to be this
mountain located in midgard the fact
that Faye a giant wants to spread her
ashes in yotenheim is not a coincidence
and not just in the sense that it's her
home Norse mythology takes place on the
igdrasil or the world tree on the tree
are nine Realms the one in the middle is
midgard how simple the other eight
though are separate worlds essentially
over the course of the game we'll get to
explore a lot of these Realms and be
able to see what they're all about but
we need to get moving first the next two
hours or so is more about combat as well
as introducing the rest of the cast it
also allows you in Kratos to get used to
atreus and see how you can utilize him
in combat his arrows are pretty terrible
in the early game but they can keep
enemies juggles allowing you to keep the
combo going and after a bit atreus can
strangle some enemies leaving them open
to a devastating attack
it's pretty impressive how seamless the
combat fits with the narrative both
Kratos and atreus start out a bit weak
which makes sense as the trace is still
a child with no combat experience and
Kratos is using an unfamiliar weapon but
over time they'll become more proficient
not just individually but also as a team
one thing that's also impressive is the
careful consideration regarding the
game's characters the first few enemies
we Face are draugr there's these
shambling corpses that attack you on
site atreus during these fights is fine
but eventually the two will have to
fight reavers who are real people Kratos
refuses to let atreus fight and has to
fight them on his own unfortunately a
trace gets grabbed during the fight and
while he manages to fend off the Reaver
he has to stab him this is the first
time he has killed a real person and
this affects him as much as it would
anyone he is shocked and cries over what
he just did this is the sort of thing
that can really only be captured with
newer technology not only is this in
engine and not some full motion video
separate from the main game but the
intricacies of the human face when
displaying an emotion are shown in full
effect here and it's really well done
during this time we'll be Brock and
sindri two dwarves who aren't on good
terms anymore they're Brothers but they
don't talk to each other they're also
the creators of phase Leviathan acts
showing to us that Fey was indeed a
warrior after this critician atris will
find a boar and Kratos acid Trace to
shoot it so we can prove to him that he
knows how to hunt he manages to strike
it down until they realize that this was
some woman's property and not some stray
animal similar to balder This Woman's
identity is hidden as she's called the
witch in the woods but it will
eventually learn that her real name is
Freya yes the Freya this is the second
God that Kratos has met and it's only
been a couple of hours she however seems
to be nice and has no intent to harm us
but she isn't really helping her case
that much I know you're
not of this realm but there's no
mistaking it you know usually people
start with a Hello first not their most
kept secret but this interaction still
puzzles me though because I don't know
what she means by this this isn't a bad
thing though actually it made things way
more tense than they probably should
have been since the Norse Realms are
split into Realms people use the word
realm to identify them this can still be
interpreted in two ways either she knows
Kratos isn't from midgarden is somewhere
else like alphaim or something or she
means that Kratos isn't from the nine
Realms at all and is from somewhere else
in the real world if someone were to
tell us that they're from a different
realm we would just assume they don't
live on earth the word country to us
might possibly be the word realm to them
which is why I think Freya believes that
Kratos is a god from one of the other
eight Realms but at the time I had no
idea what she meant by this so I was on
edge anytime we talked with her to an
extent I still am because balder assume
Kratos was a giant but Freya knew
immediately that Kratos was a god which
is strange I've narrowed this down to
two theories though Freya is a veneer
goddess and the veneer are known to have
some mystical magic so it's possible
that she was able to find out this way
but towards the second and half of the
game will meet with mimir who says quote
I'm hanging from the bloody Ghost of
Sparta this not only means that some or
all the Norse gods are familiar with the
Greek ones but that their fate is also
known as the ghost of Sparta is a very
specific nickname that no one in the
nine realm should know furthermore this
conversation with Freya also confirms
that not only does atreus not know that
Kratos is a God but that atreus himself
is one too Fey is a giant and Kratos is
Immortal and a God so atreus is part
mortal God and Giant yet he only
believes that he is Mortal this is some
nice foreshadowing as it leads to some
very important events later in the game
after Kratos reluctantly gets Freya her
ingredients she gives them a magical
Ward which hides them from the gods the
same way Fey hid them with her magic
this never gets mentioned in the game
but it could also confirm that FEI knows
and Vanier magic what's odd though is
Freya herself as she seems to have set
up a home here in midgard but if she's a
vanir goddess she should be in vanaheim
well Freya got together with Odin
because the Vanier in the Acer were at a
war with one another this not only
affected their own groups but also
others as well like the Giants who were
caught in the cross fire thanks to
Odin's paranoia to stop the Warfare and
Odin got together and for a Time the two
seemed quite happy until Odin started
using her magic for evil and she
couldn't take it anymore she broke off
their marriage but because Odin was
using Vanier magic he was able to make
curses not even she could break she is
now cursed to Forever live in midgard
and can never harm a living thing that's
why she lives as a Hermit in the woods
this is bad enough on its own but seeing
as she and Odin were together that would
also mean that her son is balther but
since balder is an Acer God that means
he lives in Asgard so not only can she
not see her son in Asgard but she can't
even visit her old home of Anaheim on
top of that part of this curse likely
led to balder's current situation
Boulder is the last thing in freya's
life that she cares about so in an
attempt to make sure he doesn't die she
made him Invincible he believes this to
be a curse because he can't feel
anything something as simple as feeling
his hand touch his other hand or just
knowing the temperature of a room is
something he can't feel he is physically
numb to everything this just like with
atreus is also a foreshadowing of the
events to come before we continue just
to clarify some information because that
was quite a bit at this moment the two
do not know that the stranger is balder
and that the witch in the woods is Freya
and balder's Mom for now they're just
two separate people that they met on
their Journey that's why tensions are
very low because she hasn't revealed
herself yet Kratos still doesn't trust
her but in a more traditional way since
she's just a stranger to them this
interaction is also why I love atreya so
much because he acts like a real child
he doesn't even bothered to consider the
ramifications of his actions he talks to
a complete stranger without even
wondering if this person is nice or not
he pulls a lever at one point and almost
falls off the ledge and when the two
meet Freya again a trace is extremely
happy to see her this dichotomy between
these two is staggering since Kratos
only focuses on the mission and won't
talk to anyone unless it's necessary
while atreus wants to explore the world
and talk with everyone they are complete
opposites and this difference in mindset
further separates the two once they make
it out of freya's house the quest marker
points us to a random spot in the lake
this is one of the few times the game
just does things for the sake of doing
them because why would the two stop here
in the middle of the lake when they're
supposed to go to the mountain
furthermore the runes on the Statue talk
about relinquishing all weapons so
Kratos on a whim just hurls his ax into
the sea due to his Insane luck though
everything works out okay as his ax
returns and the way to get to yotenheim
is now accessible well sort of the
reason the water was so high was because
the world serpentjerman Gander was
sitting in the lake him being awoken
lowered the water allowing tears Temple
to be revealed tear is the Norse god of
war but unlike Kratos he was dedicated
to stopping Wars not creating them tyr
used his Temple to reunite the nine
Realms since midgard is in the middle he
built this Temple here to be used as a
gateway to the other eight this ended up
creating peace amongst all the Realms
until tear supposedly passed away that's
why the temple is dormant and under the
water this will be used later to cross
the various Realms but at this point in
the game the two don't need to use this
since they just need to make it to the
mountain which is in midgard I know the
game is setting this up so they can be
used later but God of War really just
loves to make the player not focus on
the howl don't ask about how Kratos got
to the Norse Realms and don't question
why Kratos threw his ax on a whim for no
reason at all just focus on everything
else like this giant serpent is it a
cool I understand stand that Kratos can
just retrieve his acts whenever he wants
but not only did it not return for a
moment you also have to consider why he
would do this in the first place there
are various side quests we can complete
in the game and Kratos storing almost
all of them will say that doing this is
a waste of time and that they should
focus on the mission instead but
apparently throwing his ax into the sea
just to see what happens is a part of
the mission however right after this the
game swings the opposite way as it
actually takes into account some of the
gameplay systems one issue I had with
the Greek games was how Kratos just came
across god-like weapons for no reason in
this entry the game explains why Brock
and sindri appear in different Realms
all the time they serve as crafting
shops allowing the player to upgrade and
craft new equipment but seeing as we
travel across Realms it would be weird
to find them there but we learned that
the dwarves can travel between Realms
and can also go invisible so they're not
spotted it's a much appreciated and
rather interesting detail Kratos and
atreus will then make it to the foot of
the mountain before being stopped by
this toxic substance called black breath
to get past the black breath crit also
needs to go to alphaim and gather the
light of alphaim in order to ward off
the substance this is told to him by a
Freya who just magically appears out of
nowhere but this actually makes sense in
the game knew this because atreus asks
why she's here Frey explains that she
wants to help them with their Journey
which is probably connected to a
previous conversation she had with
Kratos where she talked about making up
her past mistakes Frey then gives Kratos
a key call to bifrost which allows him
to travel to the other Realms the only
place we can go to for now though is
alfine because we not only need the
bifrost key but also a travel Rune that
allows us to activate the door as we
approach the door we can see how
beautiful and different altheim is Freya
also gets sucked into the portal since
she's not allowed to leave midgard so
the two will have to travel without her
one of my favorite Parts about this game
is that it actually gives us the story
of these Realms God of War to an extenso
uses the mythology as just a backdrop
but a lot more consideration was put
into it for this entry it makes the
Realms feel like actual places and also
makes the people feel like actual people
because we get a chance to talk with
some of the world's inhabitants as for
the story of alphaim well it seems to be
the home of the elves which would
explain why there's so many of them here
there seems to be two separate groups
the light and dark elves when we first
enter and look at the chaos it seems to
paint the picture that the dark elves
are the evil ones and that they're
taking over the land from the light out
but this isn't exactly true the reason
two groups fight is because the light of
alpha machine is the gods of the elves
it's also very important as it's the
only substance that can activate the
bifrost but it also Powers most of
alphaim this war the two groups are in
seem to be quite normal mimir who will
meet later says the light of alphaim has
been exchanged over 213 times and that
it's gotten so bad that not only do
majority of the elves not know who
actually owned it first but for most
elves war is all they know Kratos will
mention to atreus how there are two
sides to every story Not only was this a
lesson for atreus but for the player as
well we don't get in the mirror until
after we leave alphaim so for some
reason you never revisit Al fine when he
joins the party you'll go on with your
life assuming the dark elves are the bad
guys when it's a bit more complicated
than that when one of the light outs
gets attacked by a dark elf atreus is
confused as he says why did they do that
he wasn't doing anything kritos chimes
in and tells him that this is a war and
they do not know what led to this moment
for all they know the light elves could
have started this conflict but are now
losing we can't just automatically feel
sorry for a particular group without
knowing the full story once the two
reach the light of Alpha and Kratos
decides that he'll go inside and that a
trace will stay behind since it could be
dangerous he also gives him the ax in
case he needs to defend himself as soon
as Kratos steps inside he starts hearing
atreus's Voice who seems to be talking
to Faye this whole scene can be
interpreted in a few ways it seems this
is either what Kratos believes the treas
thinks or what atreya said at one point
in time possibly while he was sitting
next to Faye in the intro just based off
the way he talks it seems to be the
latter this is further solidifying that
atreus and Kratos have a very rocky
relationship but atreus is willing to
try as long as Kratos does too during
this dream realm sequence Kratos will be
ripped out by atreus and he gets yelled
at for doing so claiming that he was
only gone a couple minutes when he may
have actually been gone a lot longer
seeing as there is piles of bodies
around the light that weren't there
before I do like how it's conveying
through environmental storytelling how
long it's been since Kratos went inside
but there is no way atreus was able to
kill this many elves by himself he's
still young and inexperienced so I doubt
he'd be able to handle all these elves
even with the ax but with the light of
alphaim and the bifrost Kratos can now
take the key and use it to ward off the
black breath before we can make it to
the top of the mountain over inner
corrupted by a dragon and must fight it
to continue it's not a bad fight it's
just such a large Beast that the only
way for it to work is for the player to
exploit some kind of weakness like using
these balls to shock it temporarily it's
kind of like the Colossus where you can
damage it but most of the actual damage
comes from the scripted events God of
War this time around though does allow
you to actually damage the boss but if
you really want to finish the fight
you'll have to play by its rules it's
not terrible by any means but I will
always prefer fights that allow you to
actually use your whole kit the reason
we even fought this Beast to begin with
though is because sinjuru is being
attacked by it and atreus wanted to save
him surprisingly Kratos agreed to this
plan likely because injury is of use to
him as thanks syndra gives atreus
mistletoe arrows in a lightning
enchantment atreus's lightning arrows
especially when ranked up are insanely
powerful his arrows before could barely
take down a single enemy but now he can
handle swarms on his own compare that
with some of the summons he'll get later
in the game and fights become laughably
easy the mistletoe arrows don't get too
much use though sadly since Freya will
ask him to burn any he sees since she
claims that they are wicked plus his
stratbreak so we have to waste an error
repairing his strap as the two approach
the top of the mountain we overhear a
conversation between four men the first
one is balder with the other two being
his nephews magni and Modi the three of
them are talking to mamir who is stuck
to a tree and are asking where Kratos
went this question was likely Ed Odin's
request in fact the whole thing
regarding balder and Kratos in the intro
was also likely at Odin's request Odin
is very paranoid he wants to conquer all
that he can and even if you mean no harm
to him now that doesn't mean you won't
later so he'll stomp you out even before
you start he attempted to do this with
the Giants as well which led to their
disappearance as we saw earlier
jotenheim's Tower is gone that's because
with the help of tear the giant sealed
off their entrance so that no one could
enter allowing them to live in peace
away from Odin and the Acer that's why
the interaction with balder is so
important because balder believes Kratos
to be a giant and seeing as they all
sealed themselves away years ago how was
one here now that's why he was sent to
check it out with the hope that they
might be able to find yotenheim again
Odin once again did this because he
wants to make sure all opposition is
stomped out but also to prevent his own
death most if not all Giants have the
ability to see into the future and it is
prophesied is that during Ragnarok Onin
will die Ragnarok for those unaware is a
world ending event in which all the gods
and Giants fight and just about everyone
dies Odin dies during this event so
after learning of his inevitable death
he wants to stop that from happening
that's why he wants to go to yotenheim
and find the Giants because if he can
gain the ability to see into the future
then he'll always know who will kill him
and how he'll die the mirror however is
not willing to help Odin due to their
past Odin does not like the Giants and
after killing quite a few of them he
blamed Amir in tear for helping them
Odin really wasn't far off either as
they did converse with the Giants quite
a bit and are the only two people that
have bifrost eyes so instead of the key
Kratos uses they can use their eyes to
activate the temple due to this supposed
betrayal mamir has been imprisoned on
top of this mountain for the past 109
years obviously mamir is very reluctant
to help balder since he's allied with
Odin but even if he wanted to he likely
wouldn't be able to help since Kratos
had that Rune placed on his neck by
Freya the reason the three consult mamir
is because he is known as the smartest
man alive if you have a question he'll
likely know the answer but as I said he
refuses to help so the trio leaves just
in time for Kratos and atres to arrive
and meet the man himself after learning
about the two's goals to spread Faye's
ashes at the highest peak he corrects
them and says that it's not here in
midgard but in yotenheim that's why I
mentioned yotenheim earlier because
that's where they will end up going
eventually confused by this statement
though Kratos thinks it over asking
himself if this is what Faye meant by
the highest peak in all the Realms he
realizes that he was wrong and asks him
how to get to yotenheim so the two
strike a deal if they get mimir off the
tree he'll help them the two don't
really have a choice though because
mamir is the only one who knows how to
reach schottenheim so Kratos cuts off
his head and takes him to freyas and
she's the only one that knows any
powerful healing magic once they reach
freya's house is around the time her
true identity as Freya is revealed as
she spits in his face before mimir
apologizes as we discussed before Odin
and Freya got married so that the war
between the Acer and the Vanier would
stop this plan was concocted by mamir
but seeing as Freya is now cursed it
makes sense that she would also blame
Amir for her current condition now that
we have mamir though the game starts to
open up a bit people will start asking
Kratos for favors and one of the
optional Realms might be available
depending on how much you've explored
we'll talk about this towards the end
though so for now let's just stick to
the main quest a lot of the information
regarding the mirror and all the other
events in the game like Odin and freya's
marriage Ragnarok and tear can all be
attributed back to mamir himself he is
the definition of a lore dump as most of
his stories can last over a minute long
giving all this information to one
character is a flaw in the writing but
mimir never felt like a lore dump due to
how well utilized he is in the story
mamir is the smartest man alive with the
Norse mythology his whole stick is to
answer any question someone has so if
anyone's going to go on a long rant
about something it's him and because
this was related to the player upon
meeting him you can't stop and think how
does he know all this or why does he
keep talking because that's been his
whole job for hundreds of years his
appearance not only adds more layers to
the team but also technically encourages
and discourages fast travel when using
Mystic gateways when we will talk with
atreus about certain details mostly
pertaining to the main quest but when
traveling via boat memory will talk
about optional stories like the marriage
between Odin and Freya furthermore he
will also clarify information for a
trace when visiting the shrines and on
the chance that you've found some before
meeting him those conversations are
delicated to the boat so that you never
miss out being with mamir was rather
comforting because whenever something
insane was happening in the story I knew
he would be able to explain away the
confusion mamir is also part of one
other impressive detail within god of
war and that's the game's smaller
details a bit later we will come across
the mine shaft we visited earlier to get
to the mountain but when we arrive mamir
will warn Kratos about a dragon attack
Kratos chimes in and says that they've
already killed it furthermore if you
solve a Future Puzzle without the hint
Mommy will mention how they didn't need
it a trace will also get matted Century
later in the game instead of his cheery
attitude he'll have more of a depressed
tone and one of the major questions
Kratos asks them Amir is about balder's
invincibility sadly mamir can say
because Freya likely cursed him when he
would survived but that's not important
it's that these interactions really show
how well designed the game is and how
much care was put into these smaller
details I haven't seen a game do
something this meticulous this many
times in such a long time if ever some
games might completely ignore these
details but it's as if Santa Monica went
through every scene in the game and
thought of as many ways to break it now
obviously they weren't able to fix every
single scene as we talked about
previously but just this many details
alone deserve some recognition once we
get mimir he tells us we'll need to
carve a magical Rune into that gate that
we closed earlier but to do that we need
a magical chisel we run into another
problem though because the weight of
this location is flooded so we need your
mcginner to move so the water level can
lower but he only speaks one language
which is an ancient one that only he
knows thankfully the smartest man alive
is able to assist us once we make it to
this Frozen land we'll need to complete
various puzzles to actually get the
Chisel but we weren't quick enough
oh yeah
[Music]
magni and Modi have arrived and are here
for us even though it's a proper 2v2
fight Kratos is technically outnumbered
since the trace isn't as powerful as
these three but like I said his
lightning arrows are very powerful
especially in this fight to succeed in
this fight you're going to need atreus
not just as amicio but also as a
long-range fighter it forces you to work
with atreus which also connects to the
theme of the story as you and Kratos
can't do this alone magni and Modi have
their own team move called the snow
blind and they even have a combo move
where magni throws Modi into the air and
Deals lightning damage it's a 2v2 fight
where the ones with a better teamwork
come out on top the fight against magni
and Modi is not only the best fight in
the main quest to me but it's also
starting the best sequence in the game
the next 40 minutes are probably the
best moments of God of War 2018 and
maybe the whole series I've never seen
this much consistency in a row
throughout the whole franchise and it
all starts with this
no
[Applause]
[Music]
how did you for the first time in years
Kratos has killed another God yes magni
was a lesser-known God but his lineage
includes balder Thor and Odin some of
the strongest gods in the pantheon this
without a doubt is going to come with
some consequences sadly that doesn't
actually happen but we'll speak about
this later because even if nothing does
happen the thought that something will
happen is very much present around this
time atreus will start to fall ill and
cough up some blood this is due to his
godhood atrey says the body of a God but
the mind of a mortal he has heightened
strength willpower and emotions that
come with being a God but also has the
mind of a mortal he is unaware of his
own limits his mind and body are going
against each other which is manifesting
in this illness the only way for this to
go away is for Kratos to tell atreus who
he really is but Kratos refuses to he
knows what comes from being a God and
that is something he never wants his son
to experience this however will continue
to get worse especially when he goes
unconscious despite her being a God he
rushes to freya's Aid which is something
Kratos would never do unless it's
absolutely necessary we can see though
how nervous Kratos is because he's
pacing back and forth waiting for the
elevator to rise to make matters worse
someone blew the horn to summon the
world Serpent and the world has gotten
darker this really expands the view of
God of War and also adds to the
intensity because it really settles in
that we aren't the only ones here and
that other gods might be making their
move and thanks to the camera being
stuck to Kratos we will never see what
happens until it does it's an Incredible
use of the camera that I've never seen
done to this level before to save atreus
critically need to go to hellheim and
retrieve a rare item the problem though
is that helheim is so cold that ice
attacks will do no damage which is the
main power of the ax but there is still
one weapon we know of that can get the
job done
foreign
[Music]
Spartan
the blades and Athena are back Kratos
has returned to his old ways his Greek
past is coming back to haunt him again
Athena and the blades represent kratos's
past he metaphorically and literally is
putting the chains of his past back on
him all in an effort to save his son
these blades were also under the
floorboards of his own home they were
always there which makes the fight with
balder so much better he never attempted
to use the blades at all during that
fight even though balder was doing
significant damage to him it's only when
his son becomes ill that he decides the
time was right that's how much atreus
means to Kratos he's one to go back to
who he was and all that entails if it
means that atreus can survive as for the
blades themselves I think you already
know what I'm gonna say despite the time
between each entry in an entire revamp
of the combat system the blades still
feel like the blades this first fight
with them was probably the first time I
felt comfortable with the combat is
where everything really started to click
for once one thing I really love about
this section of the game is how well
everything comes together regarding the
blades the enemies of helheim are all
resistant to ice attacks and the blades
do fire damage so every fight in helheim
will have to be done with the blades we
don't have a choice Santa Monica is
basically saying here's the blades and a
bunch of enemies go [__] nuts these
fights really highlighted the beauty of
not only the blades but the old game's
combat system because out the gate
everything was fluid I've had six games
worth of practice with these things so
there was never a need to relearn
anything the blades in this game aren't
as good as the originals thanks to the
lack of a jump button but the older move
still exist they're just future upgrades
or runic attacks now it's not an exact
copy of the original blades but they
feel the same and that's what matters
going back to the sinking of emotions
between Curtis and the player this fight
is another example if you play the
original games and these weapons will
feel familiar to both you and Kratos
sadly though after this our 40 minutes
is up and the game starts to degrade in
quality the fights in helheim are great
but the payoff is quite the opposite our
goal here is to fight the gatekeeper of
helheim which just so happens to be a
troll which would be bad if we hadn't
already fought quite a few of these
already it's not the fact that fighting
the trolls aren't fun it's just that a
troll being here is the problem I'm not
the only one to mention this though and
unless I'm mistaken this is an
unfortunate side effect of game
development as this fight was in
intended to be much different if I
recall I believed the bird in the
background was supposed to be the boss
but due to time constraints it had to be
cut at the end of the day though I do
have to judge the final product as they
are so while the payoff of crawling
through hellheim wasn't worth it I'm
glad the devs at least had planned on
something else and who knows most
kakante gets repurposed so maybe this
will be refitted for the sequel the
journey through hellheim does at least
have one cool narrative moment though as
Zeus appears right before Kratos leaves
in Norse mythology there are two kinds
of afterlifes Valhalla and helheim
Valhalla is a giant Hall filled with
Souls who died in combat these Souls
then live here until Ragnarok comes with
a join Odin in battle if you need a
visual example then go Sovereign Guard
from Skyrim hellheim however is for
those who aren't as fortunate people who
are criminals thieves or have died but
not in battle such as dying of old age
or of an illness are sent to helheim
hellheim is designed to torture those
who reside here that's why Zeus appeared
earlier he's not real it's just hell I'm
trying to toy with Kratos this is also
where mamir comes to the realization
that he's hanging from the belt of the
ghost of Sparta but also where he
reveals that he knows who the Greek gods
are how however I don't think Athena is
actually real mamir says that Athena was
a dead giveaway that Kratos was Greek
this is likely due to Kratos saying
Athena's name when she meets with him so
it seems that Athena is only in kratos's
head I'm convinced that she's still
alive because of the whole higher
existencing from God of War 3 but only
Kratos seems to be able to see her but I
could be wrong speaking of which we kind
of brushed past it for a good reason but
the scene with Athena really isn't that
important she does confirm in case the
giant scar wasn't enough of a clue that
the original games are Canon and this
isn't some reboot of the series however
after this Athena never appears again
but as I said at the beginning given the
context of the situation the real nature
behind what Athena is could be fleshed
out in the sequel and could even be a
way to continue this series so I don't
mind that it wasn't touched upon yet as
for other things that aren't important
the killing of magni sadly isn't once
Kratos gets the necessary ingredients
for atreus he will give them to Freya
which is able to cure him Kratos
realizes that he needs to tell atreus
the truth he tells the trace that he's a
God who has quite a funny reaction to
the news as he asks if that means he can
turn into an animal Kratos knows the
dangers and responsibilities that come
with being a God but to atreus's mind
was flooded by his endless imagination
it relieves Kratos a bit since that was
the one thing he never wanted to tell
atreya since he didn't want his son to
be like him this however ends up coming
true anyway as a tray starts to get
really cocky later as he starts talking
about cindery's beef with Brock as quote
little people problems to which all of
this culminates in him stabbing Modi
after they meet with him again so now
Modi and magni are both dead and yet
nothing happened in fact nothing will
happen I understand why they did this
especially now but it doesn't make any
sense the sequel going based off the
title Ragnarok is going to be centered
around Ragnarok Santa Monica Studios is
likely trying to set up a God of War 3
but in the Norse games a full game of
straight fighting God of War 2 ends with
Kratos almost killing Zeus who then
gathers the Titans and starts climbing
Mount Olympus there was no time in
between where Kratos reflects on his
actions or does something else it's
immediately after their encounter magni
and Modi die halfway through this game
and it's not until possibly the sequel
where things start and if some of the
trailers are to be believed that takes
place a couple years after this game so
both of Thor's Sons both of Odin's
grandsons are dead and it's not until a
few years later where they finally get
off their ass and do something about it
that is incredibly bizarre to me
obviously Ragnarok isn't out yet at the
time of making this video so we really
shouldn't talk about its story yet but
even if we just focus on this game alone
the fact that Odin and Thor don't
immediately hung Kratos down is insane
you could say that it's either because
of the ward on his neck or because Thor
doesn't care because once we find Modi
we discover that Thor beat him for
losing which is why Trace was able to
overpower him but once they make it to
the depths of tyr's temple one of the
traps removes the ward which also
happens before Modi died not after plus
we still have another three hours before
the game ends and there is no sign of
Thor and Odin or even their destruction
that dark sky was the only thing that
really changed which funnily enough goes
away after a few minutes I can
understand if the team really wanted to
withhold their reveal until the sequel
but there isn't a single event in the
game that points them actually looking
for the two no lightning storms or
destroyed buildings it looks the same as
it did before and that to me is strange
circling back to the story though I
really liked tears Temple design wise
it's beautiful and it also gives us a
bit more insight into tear we learned at
one point that tier was able to travel
not just to different Realms but
different worlds using something called
the unity Stone we know this because
tear has a pot and wine from Sparta this
would also explain how Kratos got here
but it was never mentioned that he used
a Unity Stone plus his reaction when
looking at it implies he's never seen
this device before on top of that the
growing attitude of atreus was also
great mamir and Kratos both comment on
it which I liked and the gameplay also
worked in sync with the story as at one
point atreya stops listening to you and
you can no longer use the square button
to fire arrows he'll just do as he
pleases one thing I'm also impressed
with is how the game's quality had
shifted so much over the course of an
hour we just came off one of the best
moments in the game and are now probably
at the worst once a trace and Kratos
make it to the top of the mountain with
the Chisel in hand a trace helps guide
Kratos by painting the Rune in his own
blood not only is atreus doing that
shocking but the fact that Kratos
doesn't even say anything is even more
shocking speaking of shocking pun
intended while there arrives to ruin the
day luckily because the ward on kratos's
neck is gone a trace of course struggles
to defeat balder which is fine as he
plays into his Cockiness but what I'm
more pissed about is why Trace uses
regular arrows against balder but then
decides to use the much stronger
lightning arrows against Kratos he's
only doing this because Kratos keeps
telling him to stop fighting and atreus
won't listen which once again is fine
but I'm fairly certain that atreus even
at this point in the game hates balder
more than his own father which is why
him using the lightning arrows on Kratos
is very confusing Kratos also gets
stabbed in the hip by some rock that
seems to physically hurt him yet it
never gets brought up again I was hoping
that we were finally out of the woods
regarding the house of this game but now
we're being dragged back into the worst
of it balder then takes a trace and
leaves Kratos on the mountain Kratos
manages to gather enough strength to
jump off the cliff and follow them
before landing on a dragon that just
magically appears the three then fall
off the dragon near tears Temple and
both balder and Kratos get into a fight
over the bifrost Baldur somehow
activates the bridge without needing a
bifrost key which is questionable plus
he also says that once the bridge opens
the full weight of Asgard will come
crashing down on Kratos this implies
that the gods of Asgard can't reach
midgard for some reason which is strange
and Modi got here without any problems
unless they live here in midgard which
makes no sense plus the portal somehow
goes to helheim despite balder putting
it to Asgard as he claims he did but
even weirder than that the portal not
only sucks the three in but opens inside
the room around this time Curtis has
gone to alphaim hellheim and possibly
the optional Realms moose bullheim and
niflheim and to enter these Realms you
must activate the wheel in the center
travel out the first door past Brock's
workshop and then open the second door
which leads the realm you selected there
is never any portal opening action like
this scene has so it's incredibly
inconsistent also if I wanted to be
super picky the process of opening the
realm starts with activating the wheel
in the center the room spinning then
this massive light appears then it's
only after this where we see the world
trees branches making a path for us to
leave Kratos opens the door but as soon
as it stops spinning which would mean
that the light should appear but it
doesn't until Kratos uses the bifrost
key which also calls into question how
balder would have moved the wheel
without needing one plus the branches
brought it faster than it does before
just so that the game can make Kratos
run across it even though he could have
just jumped or something all of this
inconsistent resistance he continues
into helheim as a trace now gets visions
of his own which shows him stabbing Modi
a trace claims that it wasn't him to
which Critters responds no but it is who
you have become as of late this might
actually be the single worst line in the
whole game because atreus clearly
stabbed Modi so he definitely remembers
this plus Kratos was there when it
happened so he also saw this in real
time the only thing I could think of was
that atrey is somehow blacked out and
went into rage mode similar to how
Kratos did when he was tricked by Ares
but a trace is not only extremely calm
during this encounter but the rage for
Kratos lasted a few seconds or minutes
at most this whole thing regarding
atreus is Cockiness lasts over 30
minutes so this Theory doesn't make any
sense if for some reason this is
actually correct that would mean that in
this situation atres blacked out and
doesn't remember killing Modi and once
Kratos recognizes that he doesn't
remember tells him that this is atreus
is who we could become if he goes too
far this is so whatreus doesn't have to
live with the fact that he took another
life and critters could also use it as a
lesson for him but that would also mean
that to atreus Modi is still alive but
Modi never gets mentioned by anyone
again n so similar to Callisto from
Ghost of Sparta looking at this from any
angle will not provide any worthwhile
results thankfully this is the last time
these kinds of problems will come up for
the rest of the game but all of this
goes back to our many early discussions
God of War as a series is great but it
really wants the player to just not
think the time Paradox from these
sisters of Fate the Godlike weapons
found all over Greece how Perseus is
still relevant despite his myth being
taken by Kratos whether or not Atlas is
still holding up the world how kritos's
Mom became cursed the whole plot of
Ascension how Kratos got to the Norse
Realms how he survived at the end of God
of War 3. Kratos throwing his ax into
the river why Thor noden haven't
slaughtered him yet and all the other
examples I forgot to mention that we've
discussed in this video all of it when
taken at face value are cool and
interesting but by taking a small look
at some of these events you start to see
the cracks in its foundation it can be
so difficult to play these games
sometimes because you have to go through
just about every entry and ignore some
of the events of the game or you'll lose
your mind over it once Kratos in a trace
make it to helheim the two meet up and
find balder since we're back in helheim
that means more torture for our new
guests and Boulder gets his own too
balder sees himself and Freya talking
about his curse and ends up choking her
until he backs out last minute the real
balder is annoyed at The Apparition
calling it a coward before he collapses
and calls himself a coward one thing I
really liked about this entry was not
only how it humanizes a lot of the Gods
but also how much screen time they get
it also makes the fights more impactful
because we have a long history with
these characters in The Greek games this
didn't really happen we meet Hermes and
then kill him minutes later all we have
to go off of is the myth but in the case
of Freya and balder we know who they are
and why they're here but balder isn't
the only one that gets him torture here
in helheim Zeus returns again but not
just as a floating head because younger
Kratos appears and reenacts the same
scene from the third game atres quickly
grabs Kratos as he recognizes that
Kratos is not paying attention which
given the context makes sense and the
two jump off the ship and make it back
to the temple inside the temple is a
panel of tear taken from one of the
game's many yotnar shrines we can also
see the griego mega a symbol referencing
the God of War using his magical arm
mimir can reveal the message hidden in
the panel which shows tear using the
unity Stone to travel across her Realms
this Stone was also able to save himself
from Death after jumping off the world
tree earlier in the game Brock will tell
us not to jump off the tree or will die
if you ignore him will you die but the
unity Stone seems to be able to save the
person holding it from dying that's how
tier was able to hide the yotenheim
tower from midgard it still exists just
inside the Realms only accessible to
those who know the secret path tier also
seems to have created a gauntlet inside
the tower in case someone was able to
find the secret this could also just be
gameplay for gameplay's sake but it's
not out of the realm of possibility
completing the Scotland puts the tower
back at midgard allowing the trio to
travel to yotenheim but sadly the
crystal that is usually placed by all
the doors is gone thankful mamir's eye
acts as a conduit but he's only got one
the second seems to be inside the Statue
of Thor which jorman Gander just eight
hours ago so into the belly of the Beast
we go doing this though starts the final
mission so let's quickly get our Affairs
in order and talk about the side content
in God of War which is a new sentence
that had not existed until this entry
thanks to the game's wide linear
approach which I guess is a good enough
reason to give them a pass on this but
dozens of games have and will do this
system much better than God of War has
God of War has typical collectible side
content like destroying Odin's Birds
which might give a reward but admittedly
I was exhausted just thinking about
doing that but most of the stories
within the side content come from the
favors and lore tabs there are lore
markers and yotnar shrines within the
game the war markers are interesting but
they usually relate to the area and
don't provide much information like this
marker talking about wanting the Raven
god Odin to die which happens to be
right next to freya's house the outnar
shrines are much more intriguing since
some detail events that haven't happened
yet like skull and hottie two rules that
endlessly chase the sky which is how the
Norse Realms have a day night cycle
there are some other interesting details
in the other shrines and even if they
don't see the light of day in the sequel
they do provide more World building to
the game which is a lot more than the
previous games did besides that though
we have what the game calls flavors
these are okay but God of War somehow
managed to limit their own reach within
their own side quests all the favors in
this game are from withered Spirits
people who haven't moved on to Valhalla
or helheim and need help doing so the
only people who don't fall into this
category are Brock and's injury who
individually give us two favors each and
then come together for a final one all
five of their favors are cool but only
because the rewards were interesting the
story not so much the real story beats
come from these withered spirits and
this is how God of War limits itself the
only conscious people we meet are mimir
Freya Brock and sindri everyone else
wants to kill us brocken's injury
already give us favors but it's more
about the reward mimir doesn't cause
it's not like he had much to take care
of seeing as he was stuck to a tree for
a hundred years and Freya doesn't either
which is strange because she actually
could have given us things to do seeing
as she's stuck in midgard this is likely
because of what's about to transpire in
the next couple minutes but I feel like
it wouldn't have been a problem to lock
the player out of these quests since
it's the final mission plus not doing
one or two side quests in this game is
not going to lock you out of the end of
the game you'll have way more items in
gear than you can count so that leaves
these random spirits but since all of
them are only here because they can't
pass on that's the whole objective this
guy wants his wife's bones put together
since it's quite hard to pass on when
your head and arms are in two different
hemispheres but he says that he can also
let the two talk to someone who died
that of course being Faye but if you saw
Kratos and atreus were actually going to
talk to Faith then you are very wrong as
this woman turns into a monster that was
probably the only one that was remotely
interesting as the others are just
killing this guy's men so they can pass
on and then helping another guy get
revenge they are extremely forgettable
and just not interesting in the
slightest they're also only available in
midgard so it's holding itself back even
more by not giving us a chance to talk
to some of the elves or dwarfs just the
same withered Spirits with similar
colors the only side quests that come
with a speck of intrigue though are the
valkyrie fights the Valkyries seem to be
imprisoned in a physical body and can't
get out thankfully these valkyrs are not
only fun to fight but are also
interesting to learn about when we enter
helheim for the first time back when
Kratos first got the blades mamir says
that helheim seems to be full and he's
pointing why the Valkyries aren't doing
their job well now we know why they're
chained up and imprisoned the question
though is who did it and why well after
defeating all eight Valkyries we can
challenge the valkyrie Queen Seagram
once defeating her she shares some
insight into what's been going on
Seagram wasn't the original Valkyrie
queen that was Freya since Freya and
Odin broke off their marriage the
Valkyries Allied themselves with her
Odin figured this would happen and use
some kind of magical curse and placed it
on the Valkyries Seagram tried to
contain the damage by imprisoning them
in places where they could not harm
people she was likely planning on
releasing them when she dealt with the
problem but she too ended up succumbing
to the curse and was locked away since
she and her sisters are defeated though
the Valkyries can go back to doing their
jobs and bring balance to the Realms I
really enjoyed the fights as a whole
especially sea grun who is undoubtedly
the best fight in the game I don't have
too much footage of the actual fight
since she did kick my ass for a while
and didn't really feel like recording my
failed attempts but beating her was well
worth the effort one because this felt
like the first fight where you actually
had to pay attention as most fights and
even some Valkyries can be killed
through just spamming attacks but
siegren required immense patients but
not only that it was also because these
quests not only give us more information
on the Valkyries but also Freya Freya
looks way different than these Valkyries
which might be attributed to the fact
that she lost her Warrior Spirit as
mamir calls it Odin likely took her
wings the same way we took the Valkyries
during the fight which is rather
interesting just because it shows us how
evil Odin really is but also gets the
mind running regarding what Freya might
have looked like with her giant Wings
everything about the Valkyries could
also be expanded upon since they owe
Kratos for saving them and who knows
maybe Freya will get her wings back and
become the valkyrie Queen once again the
last pieces of content we haven't talked
about yet is the two optional Realms
moose bullheim and nippleheim but
there's not too much to talk about
that's not to say the Realms are bad
they're just more gameplay rather than
story these Realms do have stories but
it's really only the bare minimums that
the game could at least explain why the
Realms are built this way the real star
of the show though is the gameplay each
of these represent the challenge rooms
from the Greek games instead of a
separate menu though it's now integrated
into the game moose bulheim has
challenge rooms like killing all the
enemies in a given time limit or
surviving for 5 minutes nifleheim is a
randomly generated Arena where the traps
and enemies change every time you enter
the point of this realm is to find
missed Echoes which are used to open the
various chests and terrors in the
central chamber it's got in his gambling
system as well as your rewarder for
continuing deeper into the chamber but
if you die you lose all progress so it's
a decision about playing it safe or
risking at all like I said they aren't
bad I actually enjoyed them quite a bit
but there really isn't much story to
discuss here so there's no need to talk
about them in this video but overall
though the side content is passable it
is something I do hope the sequel
expands on greatly however we still have
some Realms we haven't explored yet and
since Kratos is now making friends with
Brock and syndra I wouldn't mind seeing
some dwarves ask for some favors getting
back to the task at hand mimir summons
the world Serpent and asks if they can
go into his stomach to get his eye he
surprisingly agrees but I won't lie and
say I wasn't worried about this the
world serpent is quite friendly but
there's nothing stopping him from eating
us so I was a bit on edge during this
section but I guess he's not as strong
as he looks though because once the
three grab emir's eye your magander gets
knocked into a mountain and the trio
falls out of his mouth that's because
balder arrives in his back first some
Revenge ignoring the fact that he just
somehow managed to make it out of
helheim despite the fact that we needed
to fly a boat out of there he Corners
them before being stopped by Freya I do
like during this scene how Credo steps
in and talks about how balder won't find
peace even if he kills Freya referencing
how after killing Zeus he still doesn't
feel at peace The Two Of course fight
again but it's a lot more annoying this
time around for good reason as Freya
interrupts every couple seconds which
slows down the pace of the fight I
really liked this detail because Freya
is cursed out to harm anyone but there's
nothing saying she can't stop them
without causing any harm at one point
though Kratos is stuck but balder
manages to escape which means atreus has
to protect him he feels the full weight
of Asgard and takes a punch right to the
chest fortunately though he lives but
something with balder has changed balder
ended up punching the mistletoe Arrow
which you'll recognize as the one that
was put on his strap a few hours ago
being stabbed by this causes Boulder to
feel for the first time in a century
this also calls back to why Freya called
them Wicked since they're the only thing
that can remove her curse on him within
two minutes three sentences that seem to
have zero importance just became
relevant and that's the beauty of this
game things may not have weight now but
that doesn't mean they won't later this
is also a reference to balder's own
mythology because he was struck down by
a mistletoe Arrow afterwards we go into
a very long fight with balder I think I
was a bit under leveled for this fight
but it was still pretty good once balder
is defeated Frey uses the body of the
giant themor to breathe frost breath on
the two but atreus has a plan and
summons the world serpent this further
showcases his proficiency with language
as he was able to catch on to mimir in
normangee's conversations and translate
some of the words his eyes also glow
during the scene but I'm not entirely
sure if there's any significance to that
his voice does Echo a bit when he speaks
so maybe it's a part of that the world
serpent then gets up and attacks the
giant allowing the two to escape the
frost this ends with all of our
participants talking it out before
balder forces kratos's Hand by choking
out freyja Kratos saves her but has to
kill her son in the process this doesn't
exactly go well for Kratos as Freya
promises him that his corpse will be
paraded across every corner of every
realm because of what he did atreus is
of course confused by this statement but
Kratos and Amir blame that it's only
something a parent would understand
Kratos even agrees with freya's actions
and says that he would die if it meant
that atreus could live this next part
though feels a bit forced but it is a
great scene as Kratos spills his entire
story to atreus saying that he made a
deal with a God and was tricked by him
so he lashed out and killed many people
because of it some who deserved it some
who didn't and even killed his father at
one point atreus is rightfully worried
by this not because his dad is a
murderer but because he asks if this is
what it means to be a god children
killing their parents constant Wars and
unstable relationships this is a really
touching moment because Kratos sits down
with him and reassures him that while
that may be true they're going to be
better than everyone and not continue
down this path it's probably the one
time I would finally consider the
relationship completely healed there
were some good and bad moments they had
throughout the story but this felt like
a genuine repair of their relationship
atreus says living the truth Kratos
spoke the truth and the two have come to
terms of their current predicament and
vow to be better you'll notice by now
that a lot of these characters have some
pretty [__] relationships and that's
because God of War 2018's main theme is
family that that's why I said it's an
origin story for Kratos just like God of
War 1. Kratos and atreus Brock and
syndra balder and Freya magni Modi and
Thor and even the smaller ones that
aren't mentioned much like Freya and
Odin are all centered around people with
broken relationships the only difference
though is how these people go about
changing that if they want to change it
all atreus and Kratos care for one
another but they find it hard to express
themselves because of the other it's
hard for atreus to appreciate Kratos
when he never shows any affection
towards him Kratos cares for atreus but
struggles to open up to him because of
his past and all the things that come
with being a god something atreus
wouldn't understand since he's just a
kid the two though were able to look
past these problems and realize that
they need to work together and support
one another brocken's injury have bitter
feelings towards one another but over
time you start to realize that even
though they hate each other they still
care as Brock will ask how cindry is
doing because he wants to make sure he's
okay the two end up also repairing their
relationship and are able to work
together allowing the two to make some
of the best equipment possible Freya and
balder however could not repair their
relationship which is why one of them
had to die Freya couldn't accept that
balder would die so she permanently
changed him Freya sod is a cure balder
saw it as a curse this curse in balder
had stayed for so long that it was past
the point of no return even though
balder was free and could feel again he
still attempts to kill Freya he wanted
the curse gone but removing it was never
going to pair their relationship it was
permanently broken the moment she put it
on him I really like that this is the
theme of the game because it's something
Kratos is terrible at the past six games
have showed us that Kratos can do the
impossible that he can kill a Pantheon
of gods as a one-man Army but he can't
punch and kill his way through this he
has to sit down and actually be a father
something he probably wanted all those
years ago but never knew how Kratos
being there for atreus is not only to
make Faye happy but possibly even his
other wife and younger self happy he's
proven that he has been able to change
and can actually be a father one that
cares for their family now just provides
for them he was still sucked into his
past once magni was killed and I'm sure
it's going to come back quite a bit
during Ragnarok but he's not stuck in
his ways anymore this will of course
cause him discourse between many players
especially fans of the older games that
don't want Kratos to change but having
Kratos stay stagnant means he's stuck in
this Perpetual Loop the same blue hope
that the game started looping themselves
around as well the first and last fight
of the Greek games is technically the
same exact fight a hydra-like monster on
the Open Sea Kratos and the games were
stuck in a loop of their own destruction
so change was necessary not just for him
but for the series as a whole in order
for Kratos to change he needs to forget
about the past and by the end of the
game he does once the two defeat balder
they make it to yotenheim and Kratos
removes his bandages symbolizing that
not only is he not hiding his pass from
atreus anymore as the scars are now in
full view but that his past is leaving
him the bandages covered his past one
that was filled with pain suffering
violence and destruction and Kratos
realizes that he no longer wants this he
just wants to be a father to his son the
two make it to the top and for the first
time ever Kratos calls atreus son the
two spread phase ashes and it's a really
touching moment Kratos also tells him
the story of atreus the Spartan the one
he was named after this is an incredible
conversation not only because it's
really funny since it's the first time
Kratos has actually told a good story
whereas the whole game he's been laughed
at for his inability to tell a good
story but also because it's sandwiched
in between two of the biggest reveals
and the whole game right before this
it's revealed that Faye is a giant
something the two of them didn't know at
this point furthermore it seems that
their whole journey was prophesized to
happen as the pictures on the wall
detail all the events of the game atreus
doesn't see this but the final panel is
briefly shown that depicts Kratos dead
whether or not this comes true though
remains to be seen Kratos is getting
quite old so it's possible he could die
during Ragnarok but as he stated
multiple times fate is never set in
stone and to be fair he's not wrong he
did rewrite his own Fate In God of War 2
so who knows maybe critical defy fate
once more but before they leave though
atreus asks about the wall because it
says that the Giants referred to him as
Loki the Loki the shock on my face was
Indescribable I have never had to
recontextualize an entire game to this
length before in my life atreus being
named Loki changes everything about the
current and future story because in the
mythology Loki is the father of
jormungander and fenrir that can be
possible in God of War since they have
been possibly alive for longer than
atreus has but it does connect to a
conversation with mamir in which he says
that atreus felt familiar to armagander
it is a reveal that is similar to
Athena's higher existence and I'm
positive will be expanded upon in the
sequel the last reveal though only
happens if you return to your home once
the two sleep a dream will play that is
set in the future it shows another
stranger has arrived at kratos's
doorstep but this time it's Thor I said
earlier that Thor doesn't appear in this
game and this technically disproves that
statement but I would hardly call this
an appearance since it's in a dream and
it's a few years later so my point still
stands the reveal is cool but it goes
back to our discussion earlier about how
Thor waited years to finally fight
Kratos despite the fact that he killed
his sons regardless I do like how God of
War 2018 feels complete and incomplete
at the same time as it provides enough
answers and story for it to feel like a
complete game but also gives off enough
mystery to keep you going which is
exactly what the first game did all the
way back in 2005. I think that's one of
the many reasons why I enjoyed this game
so much both games may be different in
gameplay story and tone but the feelings
they evoke are the same God of War is
looping again but in a good way the same
Beauty and entry that came from God of
War 1 has now returned 13 years later
with God of War 2018. the series is back
and it's better than it's ever been
before but this couldn't have been done
without the successes and failures of
the previous games the Greek games
heightened the story of 2018 by getting
us to care about Kratos and seeing how
he as a character has evolved over the
course of the series God of War is about
the story of Kratos and it's because of
Kratos that I became so interested in
this game in the first place I jumped
into this game wanting to see the angry
man do Angry things but I came out with
a completely different perspective God
of War is not perfect though as the
series is written with plot holes and
consistencies and a ton of characters
that were thrown into the story for the
sake of it I was hoping God of War 2018
would remedy these issues and while they
did remedy some it also created its own
problems along the way these games have
some of the highest highs and lowest
lows I have ever seen there are some
great moments and some terrible ones too
but as a complete package this might be
one of the best series of all time and
I'm very excited to see where Ragnarok
takes Kratos next even if it ends up
killing us both
thanks for watching
if you enjoyed the video please be sure
to leave a like And subscribe if you're
new Ragnarok is coming out in a week or
so so be on the lookout for a future
video on that game I will definitely be
doing an explanation video like I've
done in a few other games but as for a
review similar to this one I'm not sure
yet also for those wondering the Mass
Effect 3 video will be coming soon the
past few months were a bit hectic but
once Ragnarok is out things should go
back to normal I hope regardless thank
you to my returning viewers for coming
back to another video and take care
everyone
goodbye
foreign